bah bonjour et bienvenue pour ce nouvel
épisode de probablement aujourd'hui
j'accueille gates ansteel co créateur de
la chaîne youtube de flers et auteur du
livre intelligence artificielle l'ultime
révolution vers la prospérité ou
l'extinction
bonjour gaëtan salut ça va merci de ton
arrestation et plaisir est ce que tu
peux leur a commencé par un peu te
présenter comment ton parcours présente
le scolaire ou professionnelle voilà
alors moi je suis mon métier c'est donc
dans la vidéo dans l'audiovisuel je suis
un réalisateur caméraman est aussi
animateur lenteur donc un peu tout le
spectre de la vidéo et ça c'est plus mon
côté mon métier on va dire et c'est ce
que je fais aujourd'hui à 6 mais je vais
à signer en australie une sinon je suis
originaire de la franche-comté donc de
la france ce petit village sa petite
ville et ça fait à peu près quatre ans
je crois qu'on a avec marc durand donc
un ami de l'université où on a lancé la
chaîne de flers sur youtube qui est
finalement donc s'intéresse aux au futur
de l'humanité en général c'est soit
technologique sociologique il est
question de plus philosophique sur les
différents chemins d'humanité pourrait
prendre qu'aux cantons en rda
qu'est ce qui t'a fait intéressé dans ce
pourquoi pourquoi est ce que tu t'es
resserré ses yeux à ce sujet aubin je
pense que c'est tout petit j'ai toujours
été un fan de science fiction
voilà des livres d'isaac asimov mais le
film de science fiction j'ai été marqué
par le film de mike freaks donc j'avais
10 ans quand je les ai vus et c'est un
peu le film qui m'a donné envie de me
diriger vers le côté raconter des
histoires après j'ai fait beaucoup de
courts métrages beaucoup de fictions et
on continue à en faire à travers
la chaîne c'est une partie assez
importante de ma vie je dirais faire des
courts métrages des petites histoires et
je pense que c'est cette envie de
c'était intéressant pour le futur vient
de l'association en grande partie un
voyage est toujours été aussi intéressé
par la technologie les nouvelles
technologies les enjeux les enjeux que
notre espèce est en train de faire face
et donc c'est après lille a envie de
faire une chaîne youtube alors à la base
on avait plutôt été plutôt partie sur un
blog en écrivait des articles
ils vont vous voulez un petit peu mais
la science fiction analyse de films avec
aussi des articles scientifiques ou
technologiques
et petit à petit on avec le fait que
youtube aussi grandi agrandissez ya
quelques années on s'est dit pourquoi
pas faire une chaîne youtube
c'est à la mode et c'est comme ça qu'on
gère ça parce que le blog est d'accord
bas à peu près la même année en fait on
est passé peut-être trois quatre mois
sur le blog de flers qui a beaucoup
changé depuis ensuite on s'est dit on me
lance la chaîne est vraiment la chaîne a
pris de plus en plus d'importance
ouais et récemment c'est aussi introduit
au podcast qui est aussi une manière
très intéressante de discuter et démons
essaie de trouver des invités comme ça
de parler de sujets différents
donc on a fait quelques uns jusqu'à
présent donc on va développer faire un
petit saut à l'avenir ok donc ça a
commencé vers soi que ces 2015 l'année
où on est vraiment apparu sur internet
en tant que et du coup basse pour voilà
à quel point vous maîtrisez vos sujets
alors maîtrisé c'est un grand mot
ces puits sont nés des en fait on est
curieux moi je me trouve enfin je dirais
que je suis quelqu'un de curieux quand
envie de jjg aucune n'est pas un
parcours scientifique au niveau
universitaire j'ai fait
voilà j'ai une licence mais cédant
manière dans le domaine créatif et
technique du visuel quoi un montage
effets spéciaux tout ça mais bon j'ai
toujours été vachement intéressés par
les sciences la vulgarisation
scientifique j'irai et donc voilà ça
passe par les documentaires et donc on
essaie de synthétiser un petit peu tout
ce qu'on lit tout ce qu'on voit et de
donner un petit peu notre perspective
sur les choses on dirait que c'est plus
un travail de synthèse et du veau 400 au
soir
comment est ce que tu t'es fort aux
particuliers or je lis beaucoup de
livres
ouais donc généralement en ce qui
concerne des sujets comme intelligence
artificielle
j'ai lu quelques livres de
d'universitaires ou comme brahms bostrom
une super intelligence et 1 j'essaie de
voir aussi dire des papiers des articles
sur des sur des sites et quelques
quelles sortes d'articles
parce que bon jusque sur ce sujet je
vais venir est vraiment rire et tout
c'est une gamme de sujets de fin
d'article qui sont proposées quand
est-ce que tu sélectionnes les articles
en général manger une soupe j'ai une
liste de sites on va dire à moi là je
n'ai sur le site il ya un site que
j'aime bien s'appeler le futur y sommes
enfin la plupart des mecs de mes
références personnelles en tout cas je
parle pour moi c'est cet anglophone
ensuite je vais j'aime bien lire aussi
sait bien comment dire on est
scientifique qui s'appelle est là et
sérieux comme ce qui incite donc je vais
souvent voir aussi
mais simon fraser ne restent pas tu
parles du site web
oui voila sinon mon cd chaîne youtube
aussi je consomme beaucoup de nos
chaînes youtube des documentaires sur la
bbc fin
voilà c'est ce ml moi dire c'est
gravitent autour de 6 pour cela et vous
disais je suis pas je prétends jamais
être au coeur de la recherche
scientifique par exemple contrairement à
toi ou d'un pas quand même plus
universitaire et du coup comment est ce
que l'on a on évolue et et réflexions
depuis disons depuis quand même depuis
le début on regarde mais en particulier
depuis que tu as commencé de fleurs sur
/ en général ou sur un seul rallye du
général pour commencer j'ai toujours été
plus ou moins optimiste on va dire si on
parle du futur en général et j'ai
constaté ces dernières années 1
surtout en france une sorte de
d'augmentation d'une sorte de pessimisme
ambiant sur le fait que ben voilà on est
parti sur la technologie fascination
techno-industrielle les causes de le
réchauffement climatique l'épuisement
des ressources la pollution des océans
relation la pêche la sur pêche intensive
des océans et ça et qui mène finalement
à une sorte de voie de pessimisme
ambiant aller il ya un mouvement qui
s'appelle la coloc solo joj qui est très
en vogue et j'ai l'impression que
personnellement j'ai jamais trop quand
même
finalement il ya quelques années
peut-être tient entre cinq et dix ans
j'étais beaucoup plus pessimistes qui
s'immisce aussi je pense en tant
qu'adolescent enfin si je remonte à mes
années lycée par exemple j'avais
peut-être une vision plus pessimiste sur
le
l'évolution future de l'espèce humaine
mais au final ouais je me suis rendu
compte petit à petit en cirque arts
attend beaucoup de contenu qu'on avait
et beaucoup d'innovations et beaucoup de
recherche ya beaucoup de choses qui sont
en cours qui fait qu'aujourd'hui quand
même plus optimiste et c'est parfois un
peu difficile de croire que je suis une
vidéo sur internet ainsi qu'à youtube et
que je vois les commenter a tout le
temps des commentaires de personnes
qu'il faut que le mauvais côté des
choses et je ressens pas vraiment ça
pendant puis si en australie et j'ai
vécu aussi à londres est passé sentiment
donc je sais pas si c'est quelque chose
qui est assez francophones ou en tout
cas français ou si c'est plus
généralement tout cas je ressens moins
en ici ou là c'est moi aussi j'ai vécu
un peu l'étranger et je conduis en
france sera qu'en france je pense qu'il
ya une propension à se plaindre qui en
fait le plus gros qui avait d'ailleurs
insisté sur ce qui va mal mais ce qu'il
ya des choses en particulier qui t'ont
donné plus optimisme à part
l'environnement ambiant dans lequel tu
lis ou l1
quand ça parle je dirais que truc qui
m'a vraiment il récemment enfin ces
dernières années il ya eu le secteur
privé qui s'est intéressé à la au moyen
de balles et on espère donc ça ça va
finalement ça redonne un peu d'espoir
aussi enfin c'est important de rêver je
trouve quand on voit le futur quentin
eddine qu'on a des visions sur le futur
c'est important de des étoiles outre
dans les yeux de simone de l'imaginer
comme dans les zep de sciences fiction
des années 50-60 que l'humanité va
s'étendre dans la galaxie va coloniser
le système solaire et
et depuis finalement le la première de
la conquête spatiale avec le premier pas
sur la lune dans les années 70 elle n'y
a rien eu de très excitant et c'était
c'est tellement incroyable ce qui s'est
passé à cette époque y en a qui croient
toujours pas et en fait
au final quand on regarde l'évolution
récente des ces technologies en dernière
partie sur une nouvelle ère de la
conquête spatiale
ça ça m'a personnellement redonne
l'espoir sur sur ce sujet là en
particulier à explorer l'espace
peut-être aussi miner stéroïdes ça sinon
sur les énergies renouvelables je pense
que fin il suffit de regarder les
statistiques ce que les courbes soissons
vers le positif au niveau des
technologies les panneaux solaires ou
moins chères sont plus performants les
batteries je pense que ça redonne un peu
d'espoir après il ya toujours
effectivement c'est un peu une course
contre la montre
anna une sorte d'épée de damoclès est
d'une certaine manière le mal est déjà
fait venir on pourra pas éviter certains
certaines conséquences du réchauffement
climatique
mais on peut quand même voilà envisagée
ne pas vivre dans un monde post
apocalyptique à la mode bataille très
serein car du coup si on prend un peu de
recul et qu'on regarde un peu les
courbes mais il ya une courbe de la
température qui monte quelques croquis
gens mauvais sens mais il ya aussi
beaucoup de coupes qui vont au sens et
[Musique]
de penser à par exemple le nom de la
mortalité infantile par exemple ou sur
deux choses qui luttent ils vont pas
dans le bon sens oui oui c'est ça
effectivement
au niveau du en fait il ya souvent un
truc que j'aime bien dire aux gens c'est
qu'on vit quand même dans la meilleure
période de l'histoire
souvent on a du mal à réaliser parce
qu'effectivement il suffit du journal
vous regardez la télé pour se rendre
compte qu'il ya des les horreurs qui se
passe en permanence et que des unités
catastrophes naturelles et ça mais c'est
oublier d'où on vient à oublier qu'on
vient quand même d'une époque où en gros
le passé n'était pas un endroit très
agréable et je pense que si il y avait
moyen de retourner dans le passé pour
faire des jeux maman d un tourisme
historique
ce serait pas très populaire au final
parce que entre les chances de mourir
d'une maladie infectieuse de se faire
décapiter par un tour du lac la
criminalité on importe quel pays il ya
jeu pendant 300 ans était énorme par
rapport à aujourd'hui est menaçant fin
une chance de sortir dans la rue en est
dit comme ça ça ça donne un peu d'espoir
aussi sur le fait que malgré tout on
voit quand même on ya des progrès moraux
enfin progrès au niveau de l'éthique je
voulais emmener on a aboli l'esclavagé
on a reconnu beaucoup plus le droit
l'égalité des sexes et des minorités
il ya encore du chemin évidemment à
faire mais je pense quand même que tout
ça c'est des choses qui sont
positivement on remplit et quelle voix
est ce que tu suis l'actualité à
l'actualité
bon alors là par contre naturalité
général du monde je suis je sais pas
vraiment je suis pas fasciné par le jeu
pas un grand lecteur de magazines
enfin dans deux journaux d'articles sur
le ski se passe en politique par exemple
puisque les trains de tendance quoi mais
ça me démoralise on va dire parce que du
coup il ya peut-être un bis a du coup
des gens qui lisent l'actualité sont
beaucoup plus
ils ont listé des journaux avec des
trucs qui sont plus catastrophique parce
que ça c'est ce qu'ils vont plus pitié
qui retient plus l'attention est le fait
de se détacher de l'actualité permettait
de voir prendre plus de perspective
peut-être je sais pas c'est vrai que
j'ai jamais vraiment pas mal et ça avec
un oeil dans le but enfin je me suis
jamais dit je vais exprès me détourner
de l'actualité c'est juste que enfin
voila je 24 heures dans une journée et
moins de temps je passais ma voix lâche
pas non plus très présent sur les
réseaux sociaux
j'ai sélectionné on va dire ce qui est
après ça aussi engendre des billets je
pense que j'ai un billet d'optimisme
peut-être puisque d'ici fille que je
comme il peut les sources
mes sources d'information soit un peu
plus positif que la moyenne et
finalement je serai quelqu'un de positif
donc ça joue aussi dans ce côté là quoi
on a tous des billets convient c'est toi
dans la meilleure période de l'histoire
qui inclut le futur dans le bas c'est je
pense que par rapport aux quelques jours
enfin en 2019
ouais ça me semble être la meilleure
période de l'histoire selon beaucoup de
critères après on peut toujours être un
peu nostalgique mais on ya une sorte de
nostalgie quand on pense à passer on se
dit toujours c'était mieux à l'époque de
nos grands parents par exemple ou ce
genre de choses
la paix l'époque dans les années 20 à
paris ou voilà les années cinquante six
états unis souvent un peu la référence
note d'ailleurs trump a gagné les
élections en disant voilà une prise en
l'amérique great games comme s'il
fallait pour faire venir le passé on
entend rarement quand même en politique
des candidats ou des gouvernements qui
qui offre une vision sur le futur qui se
diraient voilà comment je vois les
années l'année 2050
parce que ils ont un mandat très courts
et penser un petit plus qu'à l'heure
quatre ans deux ans et puis si on pense
aux états unis des années regardant le
passé il ya beaucoup de ségrégation
beaucoup de pistes au racisme mais ils
étaient toutes dangereuses
c'était c'était pas forcément vie avant
ouais c'était ça dépend pour qui
c'est toujours le cas mais le problème
en moi j'ai l'impression en fait
finalement ce qu'on voit dans les pires
pays enfin dans les pyrénées c'est jeu
pourrait plutôt dire l'ailé dans les
pays en août où les choses sont plus
difficiles
un jour oui au moyen-orient présente
l'état du monde aujourd'hui à ces
endroits là c'était finalement le monde
entier winaj'h pendant près donc
la mortalité infantile était élevé 20 et
mm c'était un enfant un petit tu es
obligé de faire 10 enfin ta vie pour
être sûr qu'il y ait un ou deux qui
survivent la l'espérance de vie était
très basse il maladie effectivement
infectieuses partout ne serait ce que
voient les dimensions tout tout tout
simple comme les anesthésies bhl ça fait
une grande différence
quatre cas un peu contre le progrès je
dirais la prochaine fois que tu vas à
l'hôpital refuse l'anesthésié on verra
bien je sais pas ce que ton est ce que
tu te considères comme optimiste ou
pessimiste sur le vo lu tion global de
l'humanité je parle du titre de son
livre qui paraît pas forcément optimiste
de prime abord louis l'intelligence
artificielle du tibre évolution vers la
prospérité ou l'extraction est
effectivement c'était plus une sorte de
c'est un peu le côté la révolution de la
différence ils pourraient être aussi
drastiques que finalement on aurait que
deux futurs possibles à extinction ou
alors une sorte d'utopie
si tous ma gueule
et toi tu peux expliquer pourquoi est ce
que ce serait leur extrême comme ça
alors c'est plus une question
d'intelligence finalement si on associe
intelligence à la compétence parce que
c'est souvent il suffit de voir ce que
notre intelligence a fait sur le monde
on façonne finalement la réalité
aujourd'hui avec la pensée
l'intelligence est donc si on imagine
donc là on est dans la spéculation
évident qu'une intelligence pourrait
être donc une super intelligence une
intelligence artificielle qui dépasse
peut-être l'ensemble on était
intelligence humaine ont fait face à un
niveau de compétence qui finalement allé
au-delà de ce qu'on peut concevoir si
tenté que là les moyens d'agir sur le
monde donc et donc c'est en ça que
finalement c'est ce soit elle accédera
elle nous permettra d'accéder à des
technologies révolutionnaires qui vont
régler nos problèmes c'est un peu l'idée
devrait finalement le miracle ou alors
ça pour être si drastique qu'elle va
changer le monde d'une façon tellement
tellement différente de ce que nous on
en a besoin pour survivre quand on
finira par ne plus avoir un habitat
naturel suffisant
mais si on aimerait il ya des exemples
des excès qui sont assez connus comme
l'exemple du poppers clip maximize up en
français c'est difficile à traduire une
machine à daksi way optimiser les
trombones trombone aux citadins une
usine qui est gérée par une intelligence
artificielle qui est le but de lusine
c'est une entreprise qui finalement
dirige cette usine est le son but c'est
de faire des trombones 1 et le plus
c'est le fait monsieur gagnent d'argent
donc il ya une sorte de motivation de
créer une intelligence artificielle qui
va optimiser le fait de faire du
trombone
et s'il part au fur et à mesure du
développement de cet incident
artificielle elle développe ce qu'on
appelle la tige ancien général où
finalement qu'il de quelqu'un qu'elle
arrive à s'auto améliorer de manière
récursive elle pourrait arriver à la
super intelligent c'est donc du coup si
elle reste avec son objectif d'optimiser
10 sont bonnes elle va arriver à des
conclusions qui pourraient être genre là
je convertis des atomes de la planète en
trombone donc ça voudrait dire aussi les
attentes de nos corps alors c'est
évidemment une caricature je pense que
c'est pas un scénario plausible mais ça
montre bien que il ya une sorte de
découplage entre une haute une
intelligence élevés et des objectifs qui
sont semblables aux nôtres
finalement il pourrait assez unique
bostrom qui parle de thèse orthogonale
une chambre en français donc du coup ça
voudra dire en fait qu'il ya une sorte
de découplage mais entre sur l'objectif
est donc une intelligence artificielle
très élevé pour avoir des objectifs très
bas et ne jamais vraiment réalisé
qu'elle était le fait n'importe quoi
finalement suit son objectif
on a finalement dans le problème de des
valeurs inculquées aux ja et à mesure
que se dirait une audience artificielle
peut avoir un objectif qu'elle compte et
par coda peut être très intelligente et
trouver des façons très très très
intelligent très subtil de maximiser cet
objectif qui aura des conséquences
potentiellement très néfaste pour
l'humanité ouais tu te fais donc il veut
seulement que le français mais
l'intelligence artificielle qui
deviendrait plus plus plus puissante
plus plainte et l'entente pourrait
développer des stratégies qu'on sera
incapable d'imaginer de du coup
bouleversé le monde d'une manière qui
est assez peu probable
et s'il ya un gros changement de la
société
ça peut être pour le meilleur comme pour
le pire voilà tout à fait après c'est
vrai que c'est je pense qu'il faut quand
même voir les choses peut-être moins de
manière noire ou blanche
peut-être plus en niveaux de gris
finalement voilà quand une technologie à
il ya un côté positif à côté négatif
[Musique]
le simple fait d'avoir du feu d'avoir
maîtrisé le feu ça permet de déduire la
nourriture et de chauffer les maisons
l'hiver mais ça peut aussi conseillé
d'éviter incendie donc c'est une force
destructrice et créatrice je pense que
l'intelligence artificielle sims la
culmination voilà déjà il ya certains
aussi chercheur interne artificielle
notamment dans les premières générations
qui disait que l'intellect initial ce
sera la dernière invention de l'humanité
puisque passé le point où on aura
inventé ce sera elle qui sera en charge
et d'inventer des choses donc finalement
6 y avoir une
la question c'est de savoir
effectivement est ce que l'intelligence
artificielle sera un jour capable de
faire absolument tout ce qu'un être
humain capable de faire c'est difficile
à répondre à cette question aujourd'hui
on est conscient que non puisque
effectivement tout ce qui est social les
êtres humains c'est donc mieux d'avoir
une infirmière humaine que robotique et
même en termes de préférence pense que
même si des mains l'une est identifiée
elle est beaucoup plus capable d'être en
âge pendant un travailleur social ou
préférera quand même un humain tout
simplement parce qu'on est des êtres
sociaux une espèce sociale donc je pense
pas qu'on remplacera forcément tous les
corps de métiers par des machines
c'est un peu un général et du coup outre
l'aspect prospérité et l'extinction
tu étais plutôt optimiste et ça tu pense
que ce sera plutôt la prospérité que
l'extraction
j'ai envie de dire ça mais après c'est
vraiment un sujet intime artificielle
qui me laisse un peu près au milieu au
milieu c'est à dire que
reggie ok je me dis qu'il ya des
problèmes qui sont vraiment difficiles à
résoudre au niveau de l'outil social
notamment le problème des valeurs c'est
à dire comment ça rassure qu à mesure
qu'on développe ses ces systèmes
artificiels qu'ils sont capables de
d'agir de plus en plus sur le monde
comment on s'assure qu'ils vont garder
les valeurs humaines sachant qu'on a
beaucoup de mal nous mêmes à savoir ce
que c'est que nos valeurs soient surtout
si on commence à se diriger à voir
l'échelle d'un point de vue temporel
c'est à dire que les nova leur
historique sens différente de nouvelles
oeuvres contemporaines et aussi dans
l'espace c'est à dire que les valeurs de
de quelqu'un qui vit dans un village aux
mains des talibans par exemple ces
valeurs sont différentes que lumen et
c'est difficile de se dire ok une île
artificielle va prendre en compte
l'ensemble des valeurs des humains ans
c'est beaucoup plus compliqué que ça
mais surtout on n'a pas envie d'être
bloqués dans nos propres valeurs du 2019
parce que si on imagine ni à celles
développées et finalement au 22ème
siècle avoir une toujours les valeurs
qu'on lui a donné aujourd'hui si c'est
finalement 6 et des bundles robe le
mélange et manger des animaux est ce que
c'est quelque chose de qui fera toujours
considéré comme morale moralement bien
dans un cirque où deux rassurent tout
comme aujourd'hui on considère l
esclavage en général je pense qu'il
prend des gens considèrent l'esclavagé
comme comme morobe moralement
d'inférieur aujourd'hui donc c'est un
peu pourquoi je sais pas vraiment où je
me situe là dedans
j'aurais tendance à dire peut-être oui
plus positif
ouais mais ça me paraît compliqué mais
pas si je vais parier du coup tu mets
très près aussi le problème les coques
en profiter c'est un peu le fifty fifty
mais c'est vrai aussi a aussi prôné la
gouvernance
ce qu on pourrait aussi imaginer un
scénario c'est une nation qui développe
unis en premier et fanny la demande le
niveau général ou alors super
intelligence et pourrait finalement
annihiler la compétition puisque laurent
hénart dans stratégiques grâce à une
intelligence très développé finalement
le monde sera plus ou moins trouvé entre
les mains de cette nation ou alors de ce
groupe je suis pas dans ça ça demande
une grande claude coopération
internationale j'ai ce serait une
mauvaise chose il ya une nation qui a
été au pouvoir 17 et au contrôle qui
développerait c'est à dire non je dirais
qu'il ya un risque il ya risque voilà je
pense qu'on en voit aussi peu ce qui se
passe en chine par exemple on peut se
dire est ce que le système qui sont en
train de mettre en place avec la
surveillance et le crédit social c'est
faire des choses si jamais la finale
développe une super intelligence
artificielle est ce que ça va bénéficier
le monde entier je pense que c'est
intéressant d'imaginer plutôt une
coopération internationale sur ces sur
ces enjeux là et tout comme on a eu du
traité sur les armes chimiques et
biologiques
on peut avoir d'ailleurs il ya des
propositions qui ont été faites par le
futur of life institute 23 principes qui
ont été établis dans une conférence
donc voilà c'est un peu une sorte de
guide
en gros un guide sur comment la
recherche sur un terrain difficile elle
devrait évoluer pour bénéficier le plus
de monde possible pour aller vers la
future bénéfiques plutôt que d'avoir un
groupe qui décide
seulement beaucoup de transparence et on
voit bien aussi qu'on haut niveau ce que
finalement les enjeux de l'indifférence
officiel ça rejoint ici un peu les
enjeux de génie génétique avec des
technologies comme chris peur et on voit
bien que la chine
voilà il ya déjà eu un cas de bébé qui
est né avec qu'elles étaient manipulées
génétiquement pour la première fois dans
l'histoire de l'humanité
elle avait pas beaucoup de transparence
sur ce truc là et la communauté
scientifique a été relativement choqué
par cette découverte
et ces quinquas qu on est au courant
parce que ce n'est pas vraiment sûr que
en ce moment même il n'y a pas d'autres
chercheurs qui font 10 et est aussi la
[Musique]
coopération internationale je suis
généralement quelque chose qui est
compliqué dans notre espèce
par le passé voilà n'est pas c'est assez
proche de la troisième guerre manque de
là c'est souvent dans la guerre froide
la chaux positif puisque sur le futur
nom de confirmer je dirais quand même
que j'ai l'impression qu'on a passés
d'une certaine façon seuil haut niveau
des conflits c'est peut-être être
beaucoup trop optimiste mais je
m'imagine pas moins de troisième guerre
mondiale aujourd'hui
enfin en tout cas dans un futur proche
ou alors il faudra envisager d énorme
crise écologique ou de ou de ressources
pour est une sorte de d'escaladé de
conflits entre villes ont des régions du
monde qui sont déjà un petit peu
attention quand ça se matérialiserait
comment une coopération à dire hors dia
déjà des conférences je pense qu'on a
quand même déjà pas mal sur la bonne
voie il ya déjà beaucoup de contes de
conférence
organisée donc voilà il faut des
chercheurs du monde entier qui je pense
que déjà avec internet avec le fait de
la façon dont on peut avoir accès aux
publications des chercheurs tout ça ça
aide
il ya beaucoup moins de secrets après
j'ai toujours dit si je suis pas un
expert sur comment finalement le le
ministre le ministère de la défense aux
états unis développent des districts
après tout c'est l'âme est vraiment les
intentions des instances
gouvernementales
je pense que tant d'un point de vue
est-ce que tu que je pense qu'il ya une
coopération internationale qui je suis
assez pessimiste par rapport à la
possibilité d'une coopération
internationale notamment parce que
récemment gta like for good au sommet
mondial et à florida régional et voyait
beaucoup d'efforts il ya beaucoup de
gens mais l'impression que c'était
suffisant qui a une vision suffisamment
internationaux à terme d'autres choses
pour que coopérative attendait des
grands acteurs de lentilles ans
artificielle soit les gouvernements des
fans de la chine et des états unis
notamment parce que ces restes restent
les plus puissants ceux qui ont plus
d'argent tout cas est aussi des
industriels c'est alors que j'ai
l'impression que google était
particulièrement représentée dans cette
conférence
et en plus de cela il ya vraiment une
intervention de cédric villani qui capte
dit beaucoup de très belles choses mais
il ya un moment il y avait une question
qui a été posée sur par exemple sur les
armes autonome sujets sur lesquels
d'ailleurs vous avez fait une vidéo
récente que je recommande vivement et
s'éveille figaro enfin il a fait une
présentation et un moment lui a posé la
question sur les armes autonome et hand
congo via n'y a pas pris position
il a il un peu botté en touche où il ya
un peu dit bon ben c'est pas très bien
défini tout ça il ya un peu noyé le
poisson et ça me semble incroyablement
produits non troppo dit fassent de même
parce que je pense que l'intelligence
article c'est particulièrement difficile
enfin si on rentre un peu dans les
détails alors que j'ai l'impression que
les armes autonome c'est un truc
relativement simple comparée à coopérer
sur réguler les armes automne par un
croc blanc puis simple que coopérer sur
réguler lanthimos artificielle et même
sur les armes autonome j'ai l'impression
qu'on soit sûr ça recoupe ce que je vois
quelqu'un comme viany qui quand même et
scientifique la base qui représente un
pays qui est pas imageurs de l'armement
et qui arrivent même pas ce que je pense
que villa dit si je suis je pas sûr que
ce sont vos avis je pense que c'est très
politique tout ça et qu'ils ont dû se
mettre d'accord avec le gouvernement
français tous à voir des négociations
est tout simple et donc le fait que même
lui dans ce contexte ne me met pas en
avant ce problème
ça m'a pas rendu plus très optimiste non
c'est vrai que là le pas des armes
autonome c'est un exemple assez probants
sur le fait qu'on a un peu de mal à se
mettre d'accord et c'est traîne ça
traîne beaucoup sur le on devrait déjà
avoir quelque chose quand est-ce que
c'est pas non plus un truc nouveau un la
technologie elle est déjà présente pour
l'écrit et c'est ça qui est inquiétant
la vidéo dans notre vidéo à vous disiez
que le il y avait un premier filet en
gros les gens ont commencé à
s'intéresser à ce problème depuis 2012
oui à une association non
gouvernementale qui s'appelle stop
kieler woche campaign to stop kilowatts
soit qui a lancé les premiers alerte
en tout cas ils sont ils sont à la
recherche d'un traité international
il ya eu différents cas de faim il ya eu
différents rassemblements
à l'onu et même le secrétaire général de
l'onu
voilà et envies de courage un traité sur
les armes autonome s'essaiera dit c'est
cette démontre à quel point finalement à
l'onu n'a pas beaucoup de pouvoir
à l'international c'est pas rassurant
c'est comme tu disais c'est un livre que
les plus faciles à voir aussi le le
danger quoi ça peut donner que
l'intelligence artificielle en soit
c'est quelque chose c'est un mot qui
veut dire plein de choses et c'est vrai
que quand tu mentionnes google facebook
et compagnie qui repose vraiment
représentée dans une conférence ce que
ça c'est inquiétant aussi puisque eux
ils sont plus motivées par des enjeux
économiques et il pourrait faire du mal
à la société en général pas de manière
commises en autonome et mais en
développant des choses qui font qu'on
est de plus en plus addict ou est
finalement contré par notre moyen de 2
décidé de prendre des décisions
finalement c'est un peu tous les maux de
la philosophie derrière noval noir harry
si pour beaucoup de sa fête
finalement on est des algorithmes
finalement et si finalement on a
beaucoup de données sur notre corps quel
point p qui va finir sur les datacenters
de google ils vont finir par savoir plus
de choses sur moi que je ne suis sur moi
même et on ne contrôlait plus facilement
en tout cas pas forcément avec des
intentions machiavéliques
quand il faut à peu sortir de cette idée
qui a un groupe de 12 personnes qui
contrôlent le monde j'ai à dire en fait
la personne qui comprend la complexité
du système économique ou encore moi le
contrôler par contre il ya des bras et
des envies de faire du profit pour une
compagnie qui va peut-être engendré des
décisions sur utilisés étaient limités
le système est finalement tout
trouve avec le produit et et quelques
années plus tard on se rend compte que
ça rendrait des monstres et cie vont
voir avec les réseaux sociaux
aujourd'hui le problème le problème des
data voilà je sais que jamais entendu le
mot de donner au mot donné dans le sens
où on utilise avec le mode data quand
j'étais en 2006 2007 quand facebook
commence à apparaître
tout le monde s'en foutait elle en fait
de prendre des photos de l'egypte l'aude
et sur facebook personnes se disent
heureux qui sait ce facebook
ils vont avoir mes photos enfin
récemment qu'on s'est posé ces questions
là et que finalement ils commencent à
les regarder
l'europe a mis en place ni les lois pour
essayer de régulières de ça fonctionne
et si donc on réagit on est cependant la
réaction et c'est un peu une dune des
peurs ou que qu'on peut avoir sur
internet officiel c'est à dire que
finalement apprendre de nos erreurs dans
un cas où ton erreur qu une extinction
c'est pas vraiment très utile sap est
difficile alors c'est un peu comme les
armes nucléaires c'est à dire que t'as
pas vraiment envie d'apprendre des
erreurs d'une troisième guerre mondiale
puisqu'on sait très bien que ça va être
lire nucléaire et savent apparemment
être très instructif au mieux vaut mieux
prévenir dans ce cas là et c'est ses
rangs pas facile d'anticiper tout ça et
noir malheureusement on est beaucoup sur
la réaction
tu parles de ces de google & company et
qui utilise des algorithmes qui en gros
on reçoit en maximiser la rétention que
mais finalement c'est pas si différent
de de cette fable ii de bostrom dans
d'unia qui cherchait à maximiser nombre
de thons bugs ouais effectivement c'est
assez proches dont je recommande
vivement une aide de remix tristan à
risque un ancien employé de google
oui parle beaucoup de cette maximisation
de rétention et de fin de la diction
réseaux sociaux
et tout ça et si vous connaissez un peu
le trombone des histoires de trombone de
gastronomie vous regardez cette vidéo il
ya des similarités instant que j'allais
regarder et donc alors donc j'ai pas mal
critiqués du coup le l'apprécient de
coopération intergouvernementale temps
via l'onu
malheureusement non moi j'aimerais bien
que ça se passe mais heureusement les
observations que je fais ou non pas
faute ou pas forcément très optimiste
par rapport à ça par contre il ya une
autre voie qui me semble le plus
plausible qui était un peu mentionné
dans la conférence est que j'ai entendu
via virus des chercheurs mais c'est
l'idée de créer un espèce de cernes de
deux intelligences artificielles en
particulier de l'éthique de relance
artificiel ce que donc un truc qui
serait plus académique est en fait plus
motivés par des acteurs académiques tu
vas avec potentiellement des
investisseurs google est ou qui seraient
intéressés par parfaire un pet améliorer
leur image ou juste parce qu'il va y ait
beaucoup de gens très intelligents de
danser un peu pour le recrutement je
pense qu'il peut avoir des intérêts pour
des gros groupes de coopérer dans sur de
gros projets la part des billets
également compliquer son prison après
tout pas mal de coopération sur une
pensée au spatial de ces coopérations
c'est assez remarquable internationale
et le cern ça très bien marché pour un
truc qui sert à rien décalé par les
physiciens
oui oui le lâcher j'aurai enfin c'est
bien servi quand même effectivement
c'est par de conséquences très bonne
indirects après le truc en tant que tel
l'objectif était bon ça c'est vrai
plaisir aux physiciens vrai dire moi ça
fait très plaisir aussi mais par contre
faire un gros projet comme ça autour de
l'éthique de liasses apparaître et des
enjeux techniques et autour de cinq
secrets pour être un projet intéressant
c'est clair ça que c'est un des gros
problèmes aujourd'hui
effectivement le l'asu classe on va dire
recherche en ia qui s'appelle le fcf ti
un peu la sécurité de l'ua n'a fait que
grandir en fait depuis depuis le livre
de nick bostrom super intelligence nous
je pense que la plupart des gens qu'on
lit ce livre à l'époque c'est clean 2013
qu'il est sorti je suis trop même 15-14
2014 ça a ouvert un peu les yeux sur le
fait que s'il ya qu'il ya des dangers
qu'ils sont c'est vraiment difficile de
les percevoir si on se pose pas la
question est ce qu on a dit beaucoup de
mal à imaginer quelque chose de plus
intelligent que nous par définition
c'est pour ça qu'il ya beaucoup aussi de
films de science fiction qui tiennent
pas la route
quand on parle dia puisque finalement
l'iaaf est toujours une erreur à un
moment donné et fait qui permet aux
humains de l'abattre comme si et leur
territoire
voilà comme si tu parles du super
intelligent c'est officiel je pense
qu'alors la laque astrid avance en fait
un peu comme les scénarios de
d'extraterrestres voilà s'ils sont
capables de venir sur la planète terre
et qu ils ont des intentions hostiles
on arabe chez moi aucun mot à dire dans
la décision finale quoi ça va être comme
une sorte de bataille entre des fourmis
et des humains ceux-ci même pas à quoi
que voilà c'est aussi ça qui fait que se
livrent à un peu ouvrir les yeux sur sur
différents scénarios différents façon
clia pourraient façonner le monde du
futur et qui a ouvert cette sous
discipline et ses petits aujourd'hui il
ya des gens qui sont assez rares qui
passent leur journée finalement essayé
de trouver comment faire en sorte de
rendre les ja plus sûres non seulement
aujourd'hui mais aussi en sur le long
terme ça soit quelque 46 pts espèce de
sécurité en aide
du coup les livres de beauce troubles
quand tu l'as lu kaplan a cuit tout de
suite est-ce que tu avais déjà un à
priori
enfin j'ai pas je pense que je suis
tombé dessus
après certains j'essaie de remémorer la
liste d'un petit peu des choses que j'ai
lues en avant mais bon le séparément
j'avais déjà vu des ted en série ted ce
que c'est un cas un livre ses imposants
gros niveau jusqu à l'écouté en fait
puisque l'hymne c'était difficile de
démêler les choses déjà la veille avait
lui aussi des auteurs plus positifs
soient le fait qu'ils sont aussi un peu
polémique ses délires et kurt weill par
exemple un peu plus
lui c'est carrément du côté optimiste à
100% c'est aussi un peu irréaliste je
pense que certains entrevoient cette
espèce d'utopie mais voilà il fait il
fait des remarques qui sont pertinentes
aussi et je pense que ce que j'ai bien
aimé avec l'énigme bostrom sais que
c'est pas vraiment la paix la tendance
catastrophiste non plus
et après j'avais luciani qui s'appelle
live 3.0 de max tegmark que je
recommande beaucoup plus que celui de
post rock si vous n'êtes pas du tout
dans le domaine fut aussi beaucoup plus
pédagogiques ou beaucoup plus visible
aussi l'humour est visible
si le serment a dit ce que j'avais bien
aimé oui 6 non invasif deux villes de
boston quand j'ai lu je l'écouté pour la
première fois il m'a interpellé mais on
voit aussi j'ai pas trop up
pas plus que ça tiens c'est marrant
comme façon de penser puis après je
passe à autre chose que et puis après ça
on repart avec d'autres je mange ça fait
peut-être loupé quelque chose et je les
réécoute et
et puis là j'ai commencé à avoir peur
mais c'est vrai que c'est aussi en
écoutant d'autres gens ont parlé en fait
c'est aussi panique bostrom qui fait
j'ai regardé beaucoup de ces interviews
compagnie est issu y résume finalement
sa pensée beaucoup plus facilement dans
un interview et que dans un livre de 500
pages et sacchi ces mots tu peux plus
peur effectivement comme tu disais mais
aussi en voyant des autres auteurs comme
ce qui te voir tout seul si ça m'arrive
je parle aussi beaucoup beaucoup de
choses notamment client m'a donné dans
son parcours
ouais c'est sans l'hymne voilà ces
gens-là s'intéresser à ce sujet en
parler ou comme des gens intelligents
ils ont leurs arguments tiennent la
route et il ya danger
il ya on peut pas juste se dire tout ira
bien ouais ça peut le voilà il ya cette
idée un peu le scénario du roi midas
voici pour rappel a donc en gros la
mythologie une histoire de mythologie
grecque ou dionysos donna au roi midas
le pouvoir de type de toucher finalement
tout ce qu'il touche en or tout ce qu'il
touche se transforme en or son principe
qui dit génial c'est un super moyen
d'être riche
sauf que quand tu touches la nourriture
et se transforme en or c'est pas génial
pour se nourrir et à la fin il touche sa
fille il se transforme en or donc
finalement il et il se retrouve
il est maudit évidemment parce que c'est
une allégorie métaphore ou n'importe que
le mox justement sur l'intelligence
artificielle qui fit qu on aura
peut-être accès à quelque chose d
extrêmement puissant qui pourra nous
entre guillemets nous accorder des voeux
c'est à dire si vous n'avez dit est ce
que tu peux trouver une source d'énergie
propre
presque illimitées dire oui et puis il
raconte roger siffer de dyson et on aura
pu se les imagine et des trucs un peu
comme ça où on souhaite quelque chose à
la fin on se dit finalement non j'aurais
préféré ses excuses et de revenir en
arrière
ouais cc c'est très difficile en fait de
dire ce qu'on veut vraiment que
puisqu'on simplifier un petit peu s'en
rendre compte et l'approximation de ce
qu'on veut et parfois ce qu'on veut
vraiment pas facile parfois une chose
qui est très indésirable soit fait sur
le principe on n'est pas sûr qu'une
intelligence artificielle orale du gong
le bon sens comme on dit c'est à dire
qu'il ya des choses pour nous qui nous
paraissent on n'a pas besoin de
spécifier absolument tout quand on quand
on demande quelque chose quelqu'un donc
n'y a par exemple elle n'aura peut-être
pas accès à toutes ces petites
subtilités de la la culture humaine ce
qui fait que dell pourrait faire des
catastrophes sans qu'on l'ait prévoit
tout simplement c'est ça fait partie des
travaux je prends des chercheurs d or en
sorte que les ja comprennent des quelque
chose qu'on ait besoin de la voix de le
dire parce qu'aujourd'hui le machine
learning temple il faut énormément de
données pour unia puis sur arrive à une
conclusion sur quelque chose sur la
différence prodi 2i moi je prends tu es
là des erreurs qui sont grossières
vraiment détruit film montre un chat
elle va te dire ça rhinocéros 6 mois
aucun enfant de deux ans qui pourra
faire cette erreur est ce qui fait que
on n'a encore pas vraiment sur la
pertinence du savoir du notaire
artificielle de notre avis plus précis
c'est sur ce que tu as à dire en fait
les lisières dont tu parles à ces soins
des ia qui font mieux que les humains
sur la plupart des images d'eux est
électrique mais jusque parfois elle se
trompe d'une manière
qui est vraiment ultra bizarre que et
qui sait les erreurs qu'elle fait très
peu d'erreurs
les erreurs qu'elle fait sont vraiment
bizarre et qui peut être catastrophique
du coup c'est à dire que si on commence
à donner des responsabilités à désirer
si on commence à se dire ok il ya une
alternance pacifique ciel qui a la
charge d'une centrale nucléaire par
exemple on a vraiment envie de s'assurer
qu'elle va pas faire des erreurs
grossières
le résultat pour été une catastrophe ça
fait partie des dangers il ya une liste
assez grande quand même dedans c'est bon
il ya des promesses des promesses aussi
par définition quelque chose qui est
plus petit parce que finalement ce qui
nous manque aujourd'hui pour résoudre
des problèmes majeurs dans cette phase
c'est plus d'intelligence
c'est pour ça qu'on a besoin de plus de
chf de chercheurs plus de gens qui se
creuse la tête trop de l'innovation donc
par définition avoir quelque chose de
plus intelligent et qui pourrait nous
aider à aller plus vite dans la
découverte de la fusion nucléaire ou du
d'un remède contre le cancer
et toutes ces choses là c'est des choses
qui sont souhaitables dans mon analyse
est donc c'est en ça que l'intelligent
this ya aussi beaucoup de bénéfices et
on le voit aussi dans le domaine de la
médecine aujourd'hui où le machine
learning fait en sorte que dans le
domaine de la radiologie on est capable
d'avoir des systèmes artificiels
aujourd'hui qu'ils sont mieux capable de
détecter des tumeurs puisqu'ils sont
capables de voir beaucoup plus de nuages
de nuances de gris que l'oeil humain est
donc le meilleur ou radiologiste de la
planète va finalement être battu à plate
couture gremm par l'indicatif ciel et
c'est ce qui est souhaitable puisque aux
résultats de ça c'est plus de gens ont
traité plus de finalement de soins et
moins de souffrance donc si ce qu'on
veut
j'en regarde encore à ton titre de son
livre donc l'intelligence artificielle
l'ultime révolution en particulier sur
sa ce que tu penses tu viens tu es
enceinte y être c'est vraiment l'ultime
révolution c'est le truc le plus
révolutionnaire rendre à fait dans le
sens où ça pourrait être la dernière
nation et finalement ce qu'il ya aussi
la perspective que finalement on est en
train de créer mon successeur
enfin il ya cette idée que finalement
est ce que le but ultime de la vie si
elle en fait j'ai pris supposer qu'il ya
but à la ville mais la vie mais je
dirais que plus d'un an dans un sens un
anthropomorphisme on a la pression enfin
nous on aime bien se dire qu'on est le
summum de l'intelligence au sein même de
la vie sur terre
il ya aussi toutes ces idées religieuses
derrière mais ce n'est pas du tout dit
que le biologique finalement soit la
forme la plus adaptée pour s'étendre à
travers l'univers en tant que
civilisation et d'ailleurs il ya
certaines personnes qui pensent que il
est beaucoup plus probable qu'on
rencontre le mot race extraterrestre qui
sont finalement synthétique ce qu'elle
aura entrepris à travers son évolution
technologique
une symbiose ou quelque chose dans le
genre donc c'est un petit plus qui est
mis en avant par le transhumanisme le
post humanisme et pour moi
personnellement je n'ai pas vraiment je
ne juge pas tout casser ces futurs là
comme étant négatif je pense que tout
dépend de la tu n'es pas en fait de la
façon dont on voit nos descendants si on
les considère comme nos enfants comme
finalement le futur de l'humanité parce
qu'ils ont regardé les valeurs d'une
certaine façon c'est un prolongement des
spéciales je n'ai aucun problème là
dessus
par contre si c'est une sorte de
l'espèce humaine et se fait dézinguer ou
en tout cas par x ou y raison ou non son
nez dans 7 à 10%
parce que la diversifier la faire en
sorte que du coup c'est vraiment nos
descendants c'est plus nous sort deux en
deux
remplaçants et la question de savoir la
question qui suit c'est ce que
l'attirance difficile aura la conscience
est ce que ce sera si triste imaginer un
futur peuplé par des identités
artificielle qui s'étendent dans le
cosmos sans avoir la conscience
l'émerveillement le voilà ce qui fait
finalement la beauté de l'espèce humaine
et les autres espèces animales sur terre
c'est il ya quelque chose qui se fait
d'être nous peut-être qu'aujourd'hui on
sait qu'il y aura rien qui fait d'être
un smartphone chez moi rien qui fait
d'être une voiture autonome
c'est juste du système qui interagit il
n'y a rien derrière
je suis beaucoup plus attristées à
l'idée d'un futur où aussi des machines
sans conscience qui finalement évolué
plutôt que de les machines qui m'ont
conscience donc là ça pose la question
est ce que il est possible qu'un système
artificiel développer la conscience
donc on a la conscience artificielle et
jusqu'à preuve du contraire il n'y a pas
eu beaucoup d'avancées là dessus autant
il ya beaucoup d'avancé sur un tifo
artificielle ou temps il y à que dalle
sur la conscience d'artificiel il ya
peut-être que ça va venir avec la
complexité ou le traitement de
l'information un certain moment
peut-être qu'il ya quelque chose qui se
passe ou un système mais c'est pas
respectant passionnel c'est un vaste
sujet
la conscience déjà il ya juste la
question est ce que les humains ont une
conscience parce que j'ai une conscience
mais choix tout ce que tu vois un peu
monsieur fille ah ouais je prenne mes
jeux
pendant mon regard des quelques chaînes
vidéo autour de tout ça et encore il ya
trois courants philosophiques qui n'ont
identifié autour de la conscience il y
en a une qui est le le dualisme qui est
un peu le truc original de tes cartes un
peu l'idée qu'il ya des variantes
moderne mais mon idée c'est que
conscient c'est un peu séparés d'une
autre physique chose de vraiment et du
coup c'est très difficile à manier plaît
parce que du coup par définition c'est
pas mesurable c'est pas un truc et
physiquement mesurable qu'on peut pas
savoir si on dit c'est difficile on peut
pas savoir si quelque chose est
conscient ça c'est bizarre après il ya
une autre définition qui est plus le
fonctionnalisme c'est en voici un machin
fait des fonctions ont associé la
confiance alors elle est conscient donc
là l'idée c'est que du coup si on prend
à un algorithme et qui répliquent
exactement où qui fait approximativement
les calculs du cerveau est mort après sa
définition de rester consciente et puis
il ya une autre position qui s'appelle
le l'éliminer l'activisme
l'illusionnisme qui consiste à dire que
dans le concept même de concurrencer est
une illusion il comprime ma propre
conscience ça serait une illusion
donc moi je suis convaincue par cette
troisième définition et du coup est ce
que les machines sont conscientes
j'ai envie de répondre parce que je suis
conscient déjà je sais pas j'ai réécouté
water est ce que dans mars ouais je sais
pas c'est vrai que c'est une question de
conscience saadé vraiment des mystères
aujourd'hui en neurosciences et en
philosophie moi c'est un truc or serti
de milan même plus que c'est quelque
chose qui est au coeur des débats
philosophiques et beaucoup de courants
de pensée effectivement je pense qu'il
ya des illusions je sais qu'on a je
pense qu'on a le libre arbitre est une
illusion et le soin donc ça c'est
quelque chose auquel je pense que c'est
le cas même si c'est ma plaisir j'ai
l'impression que voilà on a des
blessures narcissiques comme ça de temps
en temps au cours de l'évolution des
idées
ça peut être par exemple typique oui tu
peux expliquer un peu près ce que
j'entends par le fait que le soin est
une division alors rester sujet aussi
d'un côté la zoophilie orientale l'idée
qu'il ya une sorte de deux sources qui
est moi qui ai le jeu c'est à dire
quelque chose d'un changeable d'un
permanent car si ce temps là au coeur de
de l'interview de mon corps de mon être
je pense que c'est on a tous cette
espèce de sensations là finalement qu'il
ya un jeu qui est derrière nos yeux qui
regardent le monde et ça ça peut être
une illusion en tout cas c'est ce qui
est à ce point de vue de philosophie
bouddhiste notamment est de plus en plus
les neurosciences parce que voilà il se
trouve qu'on a du mal à vraiment trouver
où c'est que cette chose là mais en plus
lorsqu'on regarde les différents
phénomènes dans l'univers absolument
rien qui est impermanent il n'y a rien
qui est interdépendant ça paraît alors
sa part est une idée assez vieilles
finalement cette idée qui est le mot
pendant longtemps ça a été l'homme qui
évidemment la source 2 2 le du jeu en
fait ça peut être une illusion qui en
fait finalement simplement le l'ensemble
des processus mentaux
chaque seconde et c'est cette
persistance gérer deux processus qui
engendre l'idée de jeu mais si je
regarde bien
soit c'est vraiment difficile dans les
transitions pas remplies transition hat
rond enfance et adolescence l'impression
qu'il ya toujours la même personne au
final j'ai absolument rien en commun si
physiquement il ya des choses en commun
a forcément mais même si tu reviens au
niveau nous semble que j'ai eu tous les
x années on a des atomes
c'est complètement différent il me
semble
donc au final la question qu'est ce qui
est si absolument rien qui reste de ce
que tu étais à 10 ans comment tu peux
être la même personne c'est un peu à
l'annoncé c'est l'idée de l'illusion du
soin puis les jeunes du libre arbitre
sas et puis ça a publié mais finalement
ça puisque l'idée que si tu as vraiment
les choix qu'on fait voilà j'ai pas
choisi où je suis né j'ai choisi mes
parents mais voilà les différentes
circonstances dans ma vie que j'ai pas
choisi mêmes mais pour les choisit tg a
été choisi mais j'aime donc déjà ça
c'est pour un gros paquet de choses que
ne fait pas choisi et qui ont des
conséquences sur ma vie je ne choisis
pas vraiment ce que j'aime
finalement pourquoi j'aime la science
fiction c'est que je me suis pas dit un
jour
voilà je vais choisir des institutions
donc on est tous finalement pris par la
flotte d'événements et de conséquences
et au final au niveau même des processus
et mentaux et dans le cerveau on n'est
pas au courant de ce qui se passe dans
l'inconscient donc moi je sais même pas
comment je vais faire pour finir cette
phrase ne choisit pas les mains et
finalement que je l'utilisé
non ils viennent il sera seul donc ouais
je finalement le libre arbitre cette
idée que l'on peut vraiment choisir des
choses cruciaux social dans la vie pour
être une illusion aussi et je dirais que
c'est parti des blessures narcissiques
donc en gros blessure narcissique c'est
que j'aime bien cette notion
je faisais pas l'expression mais huawei
cc copernic le fait qu' il ya eu lieu
tout un tas de révolution scientifique
philosophique ou six donc voilà la terre
tourne autour du soleil donc on n'est
pas au centre de l'univers
le galaxy n'est pas actuellement
l'ensemble de l'univers mon n'est qu'une
petite galaxie parmi des centaines de
milliards
un pareil pour le fait qu'on ait la
planète terre si unique que ça puisque
l'on trouve des exoplanètes presque
toutes les semaines maintenant c'est
parce que la prochaine version
narcissique là pour être la vie on peut
trouver de la vie sur mars ou sur sur
europe 1 sur d'autres satellites vous
êtes du système solaire et la confiance
cela pourrait être une nouvelle blessure
narcissique dans quelques années dans
quelques décennies on dira finalement
pense qu'on a de la conscience après
ouais je sais pas vraiment ce niveau-là
de le soit le libre arbitre la
conscience célébrant la définition qu'on
en donne quoi on voit la définition de
la conscience c'est quelque chose qui
fait d'être moi c'est à dire que les
événements qui arrivent il ya une
subjectivité crois que j'ai aucune idée
si toi tu es conscience ça c'est sûr ça
donc là on entre dans le solipsisme
audio et donc moi je sais que je suis
confiant ça pose des questions parce que
ça pose des problèmes aussi sur le futur
de des développements en robotique et en
intégrant artificielle encore sur le
fait que si on n'arrive pas à déterminer
ce qui est conscient ou pas on va
peut-être se retrouver à créer des
entités ou artificielle que ce soit des
machines android ou alors des
simulations de créatures pour des jeux
vidéo par exemple
alors là pour juste une femme de ménage
ou à l'homme de menaces à un robot
ménager j'irai ou alors peu importe si
on n'est pas capable de savoir s'ils
sont conscients et qu'on on a des objets
qui sont extrêmement sophistiqués on va
peut-être soit les traités comme s'ils
sont conscients et donc finalement c'est
un peu ridicule parce que c'est à dire
que c'est un peu comme si je traite ma
voiture comme si elle était consciente
qui finit par des comportements qui sont
irrationnels gens revenant est plus que
cela couvre toi
elle souffre ou alors on va peut-être
avoir la verte c'est à dire qu'on va
lire on va imaginer créer des
simulations dans un
une future prend plus j'étais à dix on
va s'amuser à les tuer si les identités
alors qu'en fait il ya une conscience
derrière on va peut-être créer des
génocides monstrueux en d'autres termes
on va peut-être créer des enfers et les
peuples et sans s'en rendre compte
c'est un peu finalement des thématiques
qui sont ce qu'ils sont et traités dans
les épisodes et black mirror ma série
d'épisodes comme ça où finalement le lac
et de la conscience humaine et les
dupliquer ou répliqué à travers
différents moyens techniques et on se
retrouve à faire un créé une immense
souffrance sur des quantités et
finalement qu'on n'imagine pas
consciente c'est ce concept de s risques
je précède j'entendais ce risque donc il
ya les x x risque c'est un risque
existentiel donc s'il risque de
destruction s risque c et risque de
souffrance mentale de dire que les gens
meurent les gens souffrent et l'om sans
qu'on sache que c'est bien ca plus
d'amants pour le débat aussi derrière la
souffrance animale qui a pendant dix 10
y est qu'on ne se posait pas trop la
question pendant longtemps considéré
qu'il y avait pas deux qui avait que les
êtres humains qu'ils étaient conscients
aujourd'hui on sait que en tout cas
qu'ils ont la capacité de souffrir
donc aujourd'hui on sait que c'est faux
il être plupart des êtres vivants sur
terre soit ceux qui possèdent un un
réseau nerveux système nerveux sont
capables d'expérimenter de la souffrance
est donc la bonne chose à faire c'est à
minimiser la souffrance qu'ont or on
n'affiche moins que si on poursuit le
raisonnement peut-être que dans le futur
les systèmes artificiels qu'on va créer
pour notre propre entre-temps
divertissement de souffrir il y aura
peut-être des débats aujourd'hui il ya
des débats sur le toile véganisme
alors là les associations de protection
des animaux peut-être le futur ce sera
l'association des protections des robots
ou et ce genre de choses qui offrent
finalement dit beaucoup de matière pour
des sciences fiction se trouve c'est
toujours intéressant c'est aussi une des
raisons pour laquelle j'aime bien
réfléchir à ces sujets c'est ça donne de
la matière pour raconter des histoires
ainsi de développer des scénarios des
idées nous sur ces sujets j'imagine que
tu es toi et sur pas mal de gens qui
sont très sceptiques de ces sujets quel
genre grattard exploite avec ces
sceptiques hawaï à dire il ya plusieurs
réactions déjà les une réaction assez
courante c'est tout ça ça n'arrivera
jamais parce qu'on va en gros on va
s'effondrer avant l espèce d'idée de
l'effondrement civilisationnel parce
qu'on aura plus de ressources donc en
gros si tu parles de dalles et coloniser
mars
il ya des gens qui vont dire non ça
n'arrivera jamais parce qu'on n'aura
jamais les ressources suffisantes
puisqu'on va s'entretuer ou alors pareil
pour l'intelligence artificielle de
cybernétique ou peu importe donc ça
c'est cette partie des réactions ou
alors ça peut être aussi way une sorte
de ça paraît fou en fait il ya des gens
qui disent maintenant c'est trop farfelu
c'est un peu finalement ensuite sur la
bien l'évolution de l'histoire de
technologie ou du progrès logique je
pense que le monde d'aujourd'hui
pourraient être considérées comme
complètement fort solide pour quelqu'un
qui vit en ne serait-ce qu'en 1906
d'imaginer quelqu'un en 1806 malheur
d'avoir ne serait-ce que l'idée
d'internet ou
enfin il ya quand même des sortes de
futurologue qui m'ont qui ont vu juste
viré sur certains trucs comme un jus
gamme qui imaginaient aller sur la lune
je trouve qu'on l'a fait mais ça reste
quand même des choses qui sont
observables qui sont imaginables dire
toujours imaginé même les anciens des
civilisations anciennes que y avait des
choses dans les désastres ça donc mais
une des choses plus immatériel comme le
wifi comme même l'électricité
un monde qui appartient moment-là
développe électricité le monde il a
complètement changé
et donc ça ça fait partie de le futur
tel qu'il l'était imaginé aux ménages
c'était impossible pour eux de
l'imaginer 2019 à nantes
donc je me dis même si nous on imagine
aujourd'hui des jeux pendant une colonie
sur mars et puis une super intelligence
trouve le monde il faut encore plus fou
que ça et c'est le concept derrière la
singularité dans le sens pas alors il ya
plusieurs définitions dans singularité
mais je pense que une définition que
j'aime bien c'est l'horizon des
événements où finalement il ya tellement
de bouleversements technologiques et
l'accélération du progrès technologique
qui fait qu on arrive à ne plus pouvoir
être capable d'avoir une vision ne
serait-ce qu'une vision approximative
d'un futur après l'horizon 2050
peut-être plus de 1100 à dire mais
imaginé par le lan 3000 ça devient
finalement presque futile puisque si
c'est complètement absolue absolument
pas que sinon c'était un chien de
singularité on peut pas voir de l'autre
côté c'est un peu comme imaginé sur ted
la méditerranée tu vois pas l'afrique
imaginez tout ce que tu veux mais si
t'as pas de découvert l'afrique avant ne
pourra pas imaginer l'afrique du coup il
imagine des 1050
il ya des tendances je suis pas que
c'est impossible surtout 2057 comme
c'est assez prochain on est dans notre
compte en mai 2000 sans pas remplies
c'est beaucoup plus difficile
on peut dresser certaines notamment
climatiques et on arrive à beaucoup plus
modéliser le climat sur des longues
durées sur des courtes durées mais mais
des tendances comme est ce que
l'humanité se serait répandu dans le
système solaire en 2005 c'est beaucoup
plus compliqué à dire tu penses que la
plupart des gens sous-estiment
l'incertitude sur le futur je pense moi
je pense qu'on est on surestime le court
terme et on sous-estimé long terme c'est
à dire qu'on imagine des choses
inimaginables
en fait il me peut-être même une
impatience soit on dit on a quelques
décennies d'un traitement contre le
cancer
ça pourrait presque pourrait pas le
faire plus vite tu vois mes impressions
pareil pour la fusion nucléaire ça fait
ça fait des décennies qu'on dit que 30
50 ans devant dans le futur mais ça
compte et a rebondi en bas c'est encore
50 ans mais ces voitures autonomes
réussi exactement il ya dix 10 ans tu
paries voitures autonomes mais j'en ai
mais ça c'est impossible et il sera
jamais aujourd'hui ils leur disent mon
corps est ce que ça arrive
il ya beaucoup de j'ai l'impression que
c'est un bon exemple nature parce que
je me rappelle des certaines discussions
quand il y avait un petit mois aucune
voiture tonneau imaginez une voiture
conduire tout seul c'était un truc tu
dis ben finalement qu'est-ce qui a été
compliqué mais même si ça paraît simple
on avait du mal à imaginer aujourd'hui
encore il ya beaucoup de jeu quand je
discute avec certaines personnes je leur
explique qu'il ya quand même de grandes
probabilités que dans dix ans le secteur
des métaux lourds a quand même beaucoup
révolutionner en tout cas les grands
centres urbains et c'est un peu comme si
on oublie finalement les différentes
résolutions à mesure qu'on les vit c'est
à dire qu'on en oublie qu'on me colle
monde à un moment donné il était sans
smartphone sans rumeurs ces choses là
ils n'ont pas pris 10 ans s'établit
ralenti moins que ça j'ai l'impression
que même les prochaines révolutions vont
prendre moins de temps que ça sinon les
voitures électriques sont donc en
position quel point ça a été ralentie
quand je vois ce compte et cela
commençait à vraiment des voitures
efficace manière électrique et extatique
aussi beaucoup de gens cons qui n'ont
pas cru qu'ils me disent et c'est de la
rigolade
aujourd'hui il n'y a pas une seule
échelle constructeurs automobiles qui ne
vous qui qui n'envisage pas à tout
électrique dans 20 ans donc bravo à la
tesla du coup puisque c'était l'objectif
de la boîte ça s'appelle une citation de
john mccarthy qui disait que dès que
quelque chose marche on a de la plaie de
lire oui j'aurais ouais ouais
il yad'autres des interactions avec les
sceptiques que classique
je dirais que en dehors de ces deux là
souvent d'eux des gens qui nous alors
ouais généralement le récemment en tout
cas ça a été plus le colosse aux
logiques a pris le devant sur les
surnommer interaction avec certaines
personnes je pense convaincu que la
situation va s'effondrer mais après je
pense que voilà la colle absolument en
elle-même il ya rien de mal à ça c'est
une bonne chose de mettre en avant les
tendances très négatives de la
consommation énergétique de manière
facile enfin l'énergie fossile le fait
que là il ya de moins en moins de
ressources et que les tendances le fait
que effectivement les voitures
électriques ça pose problème dans le
sens où si on n'a pas de moyens de
générer d'électricité propre mais
finalement une voiture électrique la
l'utilisent d'espionnage difficile parce
que l'abonné latry sites électricité
embarras soir desclaux nucléaire ou
nucléaire ça car à part puisque c'est
une énergie propre
je crois c'est la bonne humeur et qui
dégagent des gaz à effet de serre mais
le charbon en australie l'australie
c'est un exportateur de charbon
je dirais que c'est leur premier la
première source de revenus en fait et
donc pour pour que le pays roulant
l'électrique
ça voudra dire brûler encore plus des
charbons donc si c'est finalement à une
sorte de on se dit c'est bien là mais en
même temps et des conséquences et a
prévu après je pense pas que la solution
soit dire non en voiture électrique mais
c'est juste qu'il faut plus développés
la génération d'électricité propre et
renouvelable et nucléaire
quelques mécontents ces départs de
nucléaire est régulièrement sujet à ces
pôles et métiers
ouais mais il ya le réveil heures qui
préparent des vidéos sur le nucléaire
qui va essayer de clarifier façon un peu
scientifique tout ce qu'il a à dire sur
ces sujets intéressants est ce qu'on t'a
excuses par exemple souvent de techno
prophétisme de ouais je pense que le
choses qui revient assez souvent dans
les critiques je dirai c'est de techno
optimiste et être pensé que le progrès
technologique va résoudre tous nos
problèmes
c'est quelque chose que je vois je suis
pas vraiment convaincu que ce soit le
cas je pense que c'est je pense que les
innovations six hindous un des outils
les plus utiles qu'on a dans notre boîte
à outils mais aussi des considérations
plus éthiques
c'est à dire qu'il suffise il suffit pas
d'inventer des technologies pour que
tout aille bien il faut aussi les
utiliser de manière consciente et
éthiques donc ouais ça c'est celle des
reproches qui vient de temps en temps
pas prendre en compte
ouais des idées des choses négatives
après voilà le on a aussi un peu une
sorte de ligne éditoriale à l'exo flers
et de de parler des ce qui fait rêver
finalement aidé côté optimiste de
développement dans le futur différentes
figures possibles on n'a pas forcément
envie de passer voilà dix vidéos sur sur
le post apocalyptique parce que je
trouve qu'il ya déjà beaucoup
toute chose là dessus il suffit de voir
le nombre de sorties ciné ou même livre
qui parle d'un futur morose ou même
complètement désastreux il ya plus d'un
film sur du je pense en termes de
science fiction aujourd'hui qui dépeint
qui décrit un monde post apocalyptique
d'une certaine tension ou en tout cas
une dystopie et ça c'est ça c'est
troublant ce qu'il ya vraiment un biais
de la culture populaire peut-être tu
passes arrivent elles quelque chose sur
notre époque parce que si tu regardes
bien les normands l'instruction est là
elle en dit beaucoup plus sur le monde
contemporain à l'époque où la science
fiction était écrite plutôt que sur le
vrai futur c'est le rôle de la science
fiction ça va jamais été de la de
prédire le futur et donc si on regarde
un petit peu les hommes de science
fiction voit la fin du 19e siècle
c'était beaucoup plus positif ya eu des
jules verne c'était plus l'exploration
la découverte l'éloge de la science et
puis après on à entrer aussi dans les
arts aiea zimov qui est un des pères des
robots et nuit là petit monde j'ai pas
souvenir d'avoir lu quelque chose
d'isaac asimov parlant de robots tueurs
ou de robots qui se retournent contre
leurs créateurs et qui à annie
l'humanité il était vraiment optimiste
sur l'anglais ça témoigne un patient de
l'époque dans laquelle il a vécu tout ça
au début de cet arrière mais après il ya
eu l'ère guy roux guerre froide où
finalement un livre sur deux s'était
décrivait monde après la troisième
guerre mondiale
je pense qu'on est à une époque où le
réchauffement climatique c'est là
la plus grosse crise voilà de notre
époque et d'une certaine façon ça nous
ça nous influence sur la façon dont on
pense au futur et notamment les
écrivains de science fiction
maintenant après tu dis que tu es
teychenné de flers est très optimiste et
elle vous avez abordé quand même pas mal
du sujet aussi
moi je voyais on va dire par des robots
tueurs à plusieurs aussi mentionné les
truies de collapse au logis de problèmes
avec les intelligences artificielles
oui enfin ça va aller je pense que
c'était faut aussi être intéressés à
d'avoir un regard assez large et à
prendre en compte
parce que finalement le futur voilà il
peut aller dans tous les sens et soit
aussi de réfléchir aux problèmes
éthiques aux problèmes technologiques
sur même le transhumanisme ça a des bons
côtés un vire en théorie le
transhumanisme s'est amélioré la
condition humaine par le biais de la
science la technologie
c'est une extension de l'humanisme et
d'humanisme jusqu'à preuve du contraire
ça a quand même été très bénéfique pour
l'humanité le siècle des lumières et le
le fait que la science a guidé le plus
en plus notre espèce
pour éclairer le la sécurité
l'obscurantisme religieux qui était un
petit peu ambiant au moyen-âge notamment
donc voir si on imagine un futur qui
s'humanise beaucoup de bons côtés mais
aussi des côtés plus inquiétant où on
peut se poser la question la nature
d'humanité ce qu'on va pas finalement
qu'est ce que c'est qu'être humain c'est
une bonne idée de fusionner machine
il est problématique sur le fait que
seulement remplacer nos membres
biologique
c'est une bonne chose je pense que c'est
intéressant d'avoir un regard assez
neutre il explorait les différentes
possibilités et après on peut imaginer
différents sites et ses différents
scénarios et c'est effectivement aussi
il ya une des raisons pour laquelle la
science fiction a souvent parle plus de
dystopique d'utopie simplement est ce
que pour raconter une bonne histoire
une des règles c'est de créer du conflit
c'est difficile de créer du confit dans
un monde utopique où tout est parfait et
a absolument aucun individu qui est
mécontent
forcément si ça c'est le début de
l'histoire ça vaut difficile de créer
quelque chose d'intéressant
parfois si le débit l'histoire appui il
se passe un truc bizarre oui ou alors on
se rend compte qu'il ya quelque chose de
louche derrière cette réussite est
parfaite et en fait j'ai mon cette
manipulation ou un truc comme ça et
parce que soit le dans certains discours
du futur zizou ou l'absolu on va dire il
ya une vision très très très peu nuancé
est très très heureux soient ultra
optimistes soit ultra pessimiste et
souvent ces genres approches sont très
problématiques parce que elles sont là
manque de nuance or que voit un truc que
je trouve que faisait très très bien
dans ce bris de chaîne c'est montrer
qu'ils ont les preuves sont complexes et
qu'il ya plein de nuances et il ya plein
de questions à se poser il ya beaucoup
de problèmes éthiques notamment à se
poser ouais on essaie d'être des tracés
nuances de gris on va dire mais oui
effectivement les très trop absolue si
je n'avais jamais parce que finalement
on voit bien que le il a eu beaucoup de
futurs locaux vu juste sur le futur des
causes d'erreurs
on a tous et on a déjà vu des images des
pentes comment les gens envoyé l'an 2000
en 2006 a souvent été considéré comme le
cette espèce de futures il fallait
imaginer le demi de coin c'était sous
toutes les langues et donc il ya eu des
dessins un conte effet on imagine
exemple des gens voyager en voiture
volante
ça c'était le truc le plus populaire je
tairai cop10 molène des futures
aujourd'hui on se rend compte que
finalement voiture volante est ce que
c'est vraiment souhaitable
ce serait mieux de dix voitures autonome
et deux peut-être sous terre comme
l'admet ce que propose de le faire et
que de boeing company parce que tu
manges tu peux aller plus facilement sur
plusieurs niveaux sous-terre que dans
les recoins et puis il ya tous les
problèmes de six mois aura trafic aérien
au dessus d'une ville c'est pas
forcément génial si tu imagines des
accidents où le bruit sécurité ouais
c'est ça c'est un casse tête et du cou
aussi au niveau des prédictions à faire
sur le futur faut être prêt dans le
futur et est compliquée et du coup tout
ce qui annonce des trucs beaucoup trop
déterminisme d'entre nous on doit être
comme ça ouais voilà surtout autre bonne
idée date je pense que c'est une des
erreurs les plus violemment aux tornades
bien c'est rare que ça arrive les dates
mais moi on a t'il artificielle que tu
regardais les premières générations avec
le après 1956 où le terme était
artificielle a été trouvé lé père
fondateur du domaine il disait en gros
et dans 20 ans il machine sera capable
de faire tout ce qu'un être humain soit
capable de faire on est toujours en
train d'attendre ce jour-là nous il est
beaucoup d'optimisme dans les
différentes vagues de recherche dans
différents domaines
je pense que quand tu vois en 1969
l'homme atterrir sur la ligne pour la
première fois
tu dis en 1991 se rassure marc formule
900 en 2002 en 2010 9 en or à coloniser
les lunes de jupiter
ouais si on aurait dû être comme ça
c'est vrai que c'est dommage mais une
différence n différents facteurs qui
font que c'était pas économiquement
viable et puis c'était pas aussi nous
non plus
pour ça il faut être prudent ce qu'ils
perdent et des choses dont absolument
pas idée qui vont arriver qui vont
chambouler des domaines je veux dire il
suffit déjà des fois il suffit qu'une
personne voilà meurt pas remplies
quelqu'un qui était imaginé par africain
j'aime beaucoup elon musk beaucoup de
raisons parce que quand on pense au
futur on a on voit ce qui fait en terme
de ces compagnies différentes compagnies
elles ont toutes un but
ces buts sont liées à faire le en sorte
que le futur soit une bénéfique on va
accélérer l'avènement des énergies
renouvelables avec tesla et ce large et
y aller sur mars
c est donc lui si la main il arrive un
accident quelque chose ça peut ralentir
le problème est donc pas ce qu'il a il
décrit ce métier tout ou une guerre
enfin voilà et pour tout ce qui peut
influencer ce qui a fait que si les
états unis se sont déjà intéressés après
l'épisode plusieurs escapades sous la
lune s'il ya de la guerre du vietnam y
avait le fait que les russes s'étaient
tues de la course mais le boulot de
typiquement s'il n'y avait pas eu de ski
qui a beaucoup réfléchi sur il ya une
époque où personne n'aurait pu résister
au point de sécurité de lire
est ce qu'on sera au score mais
aujourd'hui en termes de sécurité de
vivre ouais c'est une bonne un bon
exemple aussi la sirec quand tu
contredisait faut pas donner de date
un exemple c'est avec récurrence belle
cindy 2045 je suis à la singularité
quand même j'ai du mal à croire enfin
pourquoi 2045 ça semble assez précis je
pense qu' il finalement ils se réfèrent
un peu croissance exponentielle de la
puissance de calcul dans ce cas là il me
semble que la première date qui devra
arriver c'est le jour où les indigences
une machine sera aussi intelligente
qu'un exprimé en termes de performances
calcul durée et une chance et 2023 mais
vérifiez le avec dans son livre après il
ya ces puces c'est un peu compliqué
parce qu'il ya plusieurs façons de
mesurer elle sous entend pas capacités
de calcul qui apprécie t de stockage
présente dans lequel apc de stockage
la chine a dépassé le mans il ya il a lu
à haute voix ses deux buts en quelques
calculs iphone perso canam inc
je pense je pense vraiment calculs par
seconde ce que le cerveau humain est
fier mais je sais pas si une machine
aujourd'hui faire peut-être cassé plein
6 2 sur les super super ordinateur les
superordinateurs américain aujourd'hui
je crois que c'est le sport ordinateurs
américains le plus puissant du monde
ça a été un chinois pendant longtemps
ces superordinateurs
ils ont une capacité de calcul plus
importante que cerveau humain mais il me
semble que le facteur selon la curieuse
décès pour 1000 dollars c'est à dire que
en gros avec un laptop on ordi portable
que tu achète en grande surface du coin
aura accès à la puissance de calcul du
cerveau humain et il donne cette date
2023 ou 2025 ne sais pas si ça arrivera
et je suis même pas si ça paraît être
quelque chose de fou mais en fait ça va
peut-être même pas être très
significatif
on aura juste un ordi plus puissant et
plus rapide mais ça va pas dire que le
redis ça sera un être humain je pense
qu'il ya aussi une question de logiciels
derrière typique mais a pas que le
hardware et du coup donc tu as été écrit
on peut parler un peu plus et on livre
là son indigence articielle de tu peux
présenter un peu compté 2 de ce livre
ouais alors c'est vrai quand j'ai
réfléchi j'ai écrit ce livre je pense ça
bouillonnait un petit peu dans ma tête
au niveau native artificielle et avoir
envie de synthétiser plusieurs choses
que j'ai lues que j'ai trouvé que j'ai
essayé de redonner ma pensée et puis là
je suis en train de développer une série
de documentaires basé sur le livre donc
ça sera pour plateforme futur mais en
tout cas j'ai le livre il est séparé en
trois ans en 304 même parti la première
septien historique du domaine des
sciences du ciel ensuite je parle
d'aujourd'hui l'intérêt artificielle
limité demain l'intérieur ti ciel
général et après demain
l'intelligence du ciel la super
intelligence artificielle c'est un peu
l'idée de dire que ça va être très vite
aujourd'hui demain et après demain pour
avoir un décollage rapide et voilà
plusieurs chapitres comme ça où je parle
j'aborde les différents progrès qu'il ya
eu ces derniers les années en identifie
ciel avec alpha go l'immature autonome
les différentes techniques
après je ne sais pas un livre quelle
technique c'est à dire c'est un avis qui
va apprendre comment faire d'une machine
learning ou de type man in je définis
est ce que c'est il ya aussi un risque
qu'elle soit un passage plus sur la
conscience artificielle les questions
éthiques qui entoure la tige anti ciel
dont un petit peu parlé dans cette
conversation
et puis à la fin du livre c'est plus une
sorte de prospective
spéculatifs science fiction même sur six
des différents scénarios et différentes
106 fiction ce que j'ai demandé ton
optimiste ou plutôt de pessimistes non
plutôt pessimiste encore une fois c'est
plus facile d'imaginer comment ça
pourrait aller aller mal en fait ce que
j'ai l'impression aussi qu'il ya un
souci avec notre espèce parle parle de
notre nature le fait qu'on est con et
des mamies cher issus de la sélection
naturelle
on n'est pas fait pour être qu'on compte
de la contemplation non pas dans
contemplation le mot est mauvais le
contentement
c'est à dire que on a toujours envie de
quelque chose de plus quand on a eu un
super bon gâteau bas on imagine on est
déjà pressé d'être au lendemain parce
qu'on va avoir un meilleur repas ou ou
l'exemple c'est voilà un cadeau de noël
le côté gauche et puis tu t'amuses avec
une semaine et puis après tu as encore
envie de cadeau que je suis bientôt pas
comme ça et donc du coup imaginer un
futur utopique
ça pose problème dans ces cas là parce
qu'on n'a pas vraiment on sait pas trop
qu'est ce que ça voudrait dire parce que
ça voudrait dire puis de maladie je
pense que on est d'accord là dessus
elle a des tuques commence à toucher par
amp au vieillissement il ya des gens qui
disent non c'est très bien qu'on
vieillit c'est qu'on meurt et on a
d'autres qui vit dans le but de la
technologie et du progrès c'est cette
détendre l'espérance de vie
donc là on entre déjà on est déjà plus
sur des polémiques on peut pas avoir la
même utopie pour tout le monde du coup
et donc c'est pour ça que c'est plus
facile d'écrire des scénarios
pessimistes ce qu on n'est plus d'accord
sur ce qu'on veut pas on n'a pas envie
de d'être contrôlés par des machines est
plongé dans des rituels
pourquoi nous prennent notre énergie
bientôt on dit de skynet où une invasion
extraterrestre ouais ça serait que c'est
très difficile à écrire une utopie
essaie d'imaginer ce qu'on aimerait
ouais je pense qu'il ya des choses en
est quand même d un ensemble de valeurs
assez commune je pense voilà sur la vie
c'est mieux de vis que de mourir
donc on peut peut-être faire quelque
chose là dessus c'est mais d'être en
bonne santé est malade
donc on verra si on peut éviter d'être
malade donc une société où les gens sont
malades et c'est quand même une société
qui m'a l'air plus bénéfique qu'une
autre qui voit là on peut faire listes
comme ça après les richesses les
inégalités ça rentre en side en question
puisque c'est voilà il ya des utopies
qui imagine un futur où l'argent
n'existe plus et tout le monde est
finalement à posséder ce qu'il a besoin
de posséder donc là on communisme 2.0
d'ailleurs ce qui est intéressant j'ai
appris ça il ya pas très longtemps en
regardant un documentaire sur karl marx
non en fait
le communisme ce n'a jamais été comme ça
a dû être comme ça a été en ligne on
suit notamment ce qui décrit c'est plus
une fois qu'on aura atteint de
l'abondance
on pourra donc faudra mettre en place le
communiste c'est à dire que on a besoin
d'abord d'une certaine façon que le
capitalisme l progrès technologique nous
apporte l'abondance des ressources et
des richesses et la nourriture pour
ensuite établir le communisme donc ça
c'est souvent des choses qui qui sont
mal compris et c'est possible que le
communisme sur le futur de l'humanité
d'une certaine façon avec une sorte de
système artificiel qui est capable de
gérer les besoins d'une ville ou même
d'un pays de manière beaucoup plus
efficace que nous on fait donc on est
sûrement un système décentralisé et du
coup on écrit ce livre
quels sont les trucs que tu as fait
graver leurs recherches
quelles sont les choses qui tombent peu
surpris je pense que c'est c'est par
rapport à ces deals d'explosion
d'intelligence ouais donc en fait en
gros si on imagine qu'il n'ya qu'une
intelligence artificielle devient
général c'est-à-dire qu'elle a la
capacité d'apprendre tout un tas de
domaines de tâches sans avoir à être
voilà entraînés par machine learning
elle sera par définition capable
d'apprendre la programmation
informatique et après apprendre à faire
des ira donc si elle est capable de
faire salle peu ce programme est
elle-même et donner naissance à des
nouvelles générations d'elle-même et ce
de manière très rapide qui pourrait donc
donner une sorte de d'auto amélioration
récursive un rythme finalement très
rapide qui peut donner naissance à une
super intelligence très rapidement et
donc c'est le mathématicien à edgewood
qui a décrit cela comme étant appelées
l'explosion intelligence et ça pourrait
prendre alors l'idée c'est on sait pas à
quel point ça pourrait être rapide ça
pourrait prendre des décennies aux
quelqu'un appelle ça un décollage là
c'est à dire le passage entre unies à
khar à peu près le niveau humain a une
super intelligent ce qui est
complètement au delà de nous mais ça
pourrait prendre aussi peut-être une
semaine on n'en sait rien ça pourrait
peut-être même prendre 10 10 secondes en
fait donc ça c'est un des trucs quand
j'ai commencé à enseigner sur le domaine
qui m'a vraiment marqué puisque ils se
disent à quel point on est pas prêt
finalement en tant que civilisation donc
si ça arrive de la naissance de la
semaine prochaine ben là c'est vrai quoi
non après ça va pas forcément à dire à
la fin du monde mais ça veut juste dire
qu'est ce qu'on fait effectivement on
n'est pas prêt il y avait aussi un
concept c'est l'idée que finalement on a
une intelligence qui est limité aussi
par notre biologie le fait que la
connexion entre deux neurones à peu près
de 100 à 200 hertz alors que sur le sur
un substrat informatique c'est la
vitesse de la lumière quand on fait donc
ou alors la taille que peut avoir la
taille capte pas avoir un cerveau si si
le cerveau humain est à peu près trois
fois plus gros que notre dernier ancêtre
commun avec les lissages contemporain
c'est simplement parce que ça peut pas
être plus gros si la nature voulu
essayer entre guillemets cinq fois plus
gros ça aurait pas on n'aurait pas pu
mettre au monde et la progéniture
c'est déjà assez difficile comme ça et
donc c'est pas super en termes de survie
de l'espèce donc du coup on l'a dit jean
ce qui est à peu près là la bonne
par rapport à notre capacité crânienne
mais une machine à thé l'artificiel peut
se répandre sur un réseau elle peut
avoir la taille d'une planète
si on extrapole donc quel est le type
d'intelligence produit par l'indigence
part
par un ordinateur qui fait la tête d'une
planète ça c'est des questions donc
encore une fois la vitesse de traitement
de l'information et qui peut engendrer
une intelligence artificielle des
millions une fois prises hâtivement que
nous beaucoup et fait partie des choses
qui m'ont et ensuite il ya le problème
du contrôle vraiment le fait que va ne
mettons qu'on est une super actif
artificielle entre l'humain comment on
contrôle quelque chose qui est prise
hâtivement et tu te rends compte que les
techniques les matières les autres le
plus chiant à tête le plus facilement
c'est le premier c'est bah il suffit de
l'enfermer on ne la connaît pts par
internet sauf
est ce qu'on est vraiment sur une
intelligence qui est plus intelligente
que nous aura pas prévu de ne pas être
connecté ou aura pas doit pas à
découvrir d'autres moyens de se
connecter
c'est un peu comme si tu est imagine des
enfants enfermés dans une pièce un
enfant de 5 ans il n'est pas capable
d'être enfermé dans une pièce
est-ce que tu trouveras toujours des
solutions pour s'échapper
donc on a un peu sur le mac star marque
dans son lit de l'iphone 3.0 il donne un
exemple assez intéressant sur ce sujet
là puisqu'il imagine que si on a une
assise artificielle qui a été créée par
exemple dans une entreprise et puis que
le sillon et l'apprenti que c'est sage
donc il y demande à certaines personnes
de garder un oeil sur la tige artificiel
la pala connecter sur internet où ça
l'idéal pour être capable de manipuler
des humains ce qu'elle aura des
supercapacités de manipulation par
définition parce qu'elle est super
intelligente ne pourra appuyer sur des
leviers émotionnel ou faire des choses
comme ça et finalement se retrouver sur
internet
ou alors penser à des fans là où je veux
en venir c'est que c'est très difficile
pour un pour nous d'imaginer comment
fermer quelque chose de plus intelligent
que nous
c'est une fourmi ne pourra jamais
arriver à concevoir un piège qui
arrivera kg un être humain de manière
efficace puisque elle ne pourra pas
savoir tout et technologiques on a
inventé ce permet d'éradiquer les fruits
très facilement ce genre des choses
nouvelles
ouais c'est ça peut servir problème du
contrôle
et puis en particulier toutes les
faiblesses de l'humain est ce que
commence à s'imaginer très intelligent
mais bon en pratique ce qui se passe
dans une entreprise il ya plein de
décision suprême sous-optimale soit des
grosses erreurs soient des jeux
politiques propres profiter de tout ça
c'est clair je pense qu'on est on n'est
pas infaillible loin de là et je pense
que voilà une intelligence artificielle
à mon avis super intelligente en plus
c'est très difficile de ces mêmes
arrogant de se dire qu'on arrivera à la
maîtrise et du ce qui pose la question
finalement est-ce qu'elle va réussir à
est-ce qu'on va réussir à lui faire
faire ce qu'on veut on lui demander
quelque chose est ce que le passé en
tire piégé doit pas se dire parce qu'au
final si si tu te mets alors il faut pas
non plus se faire trop d'entrepôts
morphisme mais si tu te mets à la place
unia et super intelligente là se dira
peut-être qu est-ce que ce qu'est ce que
ce qu'est ce que j'y gagne d'aider ces
primates soit débiles sur la planète qui
est en train de saccager la planète
depuis des décennies ce ne serait pas
plus facile de nettoyer tout ça va
partir sur un terrain plus frais plus
des racines et j'en reviens prennent de
l'explosion de lille parce que t'être
talent et des cris ça comme un gros
danger c'est une énorme explosion de il
ya aussi tout à coup il ya devient donc
il ya le contrepoint de sacchi et je
pense que c'est tout réveille comme moi
il ya le contrepoint de sacchi et de
l'excellent paul cristiano je crois
qu'il est déjà charnière je crois qu'il
n'a opéré que je passe devant et lui ce
qui affirme c'est qu'en fait ça se
trouve le décollage de l'ia sera pas si
rapide qu'il imagine alors quoi il parle
de l'amrée en fait ici de quelques
années parce que c'est je pense que c
est difficile d'imaginer que ce soit
beaucoup plus que quelques années mais
quelques années c'est sur la team
brûlant et ce qu'il dit c'est qu'en fait
ça serait pire
parce que si on sent dans six leone et
au bord de dunes d'une super intelligent
c'est que tout le monde le sent tout le
monde va vouloir développer la sienne où
l'influencé autant que possible et du
coup il pourrait y avoir une course qui
du coup frais que les conditions d une
mesure de sécurité seraient mises au
second plan parce que les gens voudront
y arriver en premier que c'est un point
intéressant ce qui a souvent l'idée que
c'est plus facile de concevoir une île
qui n'a pas été sécurisé puisque
finalement la sécurité sécurisation de
diass et une étape en plus dans le
processus de développement
donc c'est toujours plus facile de créer
par une voiture sans frais juste d'un
point de vue technique et physique sur
la chaîne d'assemblage mais on a besoin
des freins donc une effectivement si tu
lui je conçois une super intelligence et
puis tu as une sorte de motivation à
aller vite
tu vas négliger la paire sécurité ont
effectivement ça donc en fait selon lui
une explosion de telligent ans aumale
mettrait tout de suite ça calmerait tout
le monde quoi se rendre au hockey elle
est là bas
après le gros lot de l'ex président
agacé que
on n'a pas de seconde chance à lui faut
avoir conçu le système et mais les
conditions de sécurité avant que ezio si
c'est là que c'est indispensable d'être
dans prospectera prospective pas essayer
d'imaginer comment les choses ont passé
mettre en place et les problèmes de
sécurité et du coup d'envisager le futur
et de ne pas voir et ses erreurs ça
marchera pas quoi exactement
bon après on peut toujours aussi de se
dire et on peut être un peu sceptique il
ya des fois ça m'arrive d'être sceptique
me dire est ce que c'est vrai est ce qu
est ce qu une telle stratégie ciel sera
vraiment des millions de fois pesante
des gens qui nous est ce que c'est
possible et pour cela il faut aussi
prendre du recul sur le fait qu' on est
loin d'être de là je pense qu'on est
loin d'être là le som d'intelligence il
y en a il ya certaines personnes qui de
la france mais c'est à dire que si tu
imagines une échelle de 0 à 100 on s'en
étant le l'entité la plus intelligente
qui est physiquement possible d'exister
dans notre univers faire que les lois de
la physique fait que tu peux pas être
plus à des gens que ça on est pas du
tout là comme on est probablement
1 donc il n'ya va aller en direction de
ce sens et à quel point elle peut être
différente de nous ça c'est la question
mais et à quel point à quel point il
sera aussi similaire finalement à nous
d'en dans le fait que parce que on peut
comparer aussi le développement d'un
type artificielle ou a donné naissance à
un enfant
certains enfants deviennent plus
intelligents que leurs parents mais ils
gardent quand même les valeurs la
culture qui ont été inculquées durant le
l'éducation des parents et ça c'est un
bon exemple de ce qu'on aimerait faire
avec une intelligence artificielle c'est
à dire les ducs et les lui donner nos
valeurs notre bon sens pour que quand
elle deviendra super intelligente elle
sera toujours alors une part d'humanité
encore c'est le scénario degrés mais
c'est pas pour revenir sur le l'humain
est au summum de l'intelligence je pense
que les gens qui pensent à ça ne pense
pas lorsqu'il dit ça aux mathématiques
parce que pour le coup il ya des
problèmes incroyablement simple allez
faire un tour sur ma chaîne prenez un
peu n'importe quelle vidéo ou avant le
printemps des deux enfants par exemple
ce prime a fallu des années côté fait
cinq ans que j'y réfléchis trop et il
m'a fallu tout ce temps pour comprendre
un truc qui en fait est incroyablement
simple
terme soient ses incalculables non du
coup imaginer qu'on est le summum de
l'intelligence ça ne sommes pas
incroyablement très gros cul et ça c'est
un problème à croix blanche simple
mesurée par exemple le degré de
compréhension des gens de les systèmes
économiques mondiaux ou de ce qui se
passe dans une cellule humaine toutes
les interactions entre toutes les
protéines ça clairement ça nous dépasse
dans ses rangs que ça nous dépasse
aujourd'hui mais ça ne dépassera sans
doute toujours pas ce que c'est c'est le
système incroyablement complexe donc
imaginé un truc qui capable mieux
prédire que nous ce qui se passe dans
telle ou telle situation
ça paraît très loin d'être déraisonnable
il s'est même déjà le cas il suffit de
voir par exemple lé trader en finance
petit à petit on les remplace par des
algorithmes
ouais c'est clair et des systèmes et
puis faut pas oublier qu'on est en est
issu du la sélection naturelle
on est une espèce voilà à qui on n'a pas
été je pense pas qu'on ait été conçu
dans le but de de comprendre la réalité
en fait on a été conçu avec l'idée de
survie est donc dans certains cas
comprendre la réalité ça va à l'encontre
de la survie c'est mieux de courir vite
dans ces cas là que de comprendre
vraiment ce qui se passe quand il fait
pour ça j'ai par les tigres donc c'est
pas étonnant qu'aujourd'hui les idées
des concepts très compliqué comme en
physique quantique où on a un ça va
c'est contre intuitif et j'ai
l'impression que cette somme aux
contraintes hui sion il est il est
récurrent dans l'histoire des sciences
quasiment de nombreuses découvertes ont
été contre intuitive
ce qui veut dire que notre intuition sur
le réel est souvent faux basée sur le
fait qu'on ait une espèce qui a évolué
comme ça pour maximiser certaines choses
et donc quand on à mon intuition c'est
que la terre est plate puisque quand je
regarde autour de moi c'est plein temps
à la terre est ronde
voilà il ya plein de choses comme ça le
fait que le titre antique c'est un des
trucs les plus contributifs de
l'histoire des sciences réactivité et
enfin comment on pouvait imaginer
comprendre la couverture de ce passe
temps ce genre de choses et c'est ça
qu'est la beauté de la science aussi que
j'ai beaucoup d'admiration pour la
raison la science et l'humanisme en
général parce que ça nous permet d'être
tocade est objectivement la réalité le
plus objectif possible en tout cas c'est
la même le meilleur outil qu'on ait
trouvé pour décrire le réel et du coup
provenir avec l'intérieur artificiel ces
systèmes là ils font pas être basée sur
la sélection naturelle
donc ils vont être optimisé pour
d'autres choses et donc ils vont
peut-être utile pour comprendre certains
voilà certains sujets très compliqué
pour nous notamment dans l'optimisation
de par mois du trafic d'économie en
physique quantique peut-être pour
construire un animateur quantique c'est
pour ça qu'il ya beaucoup de promesses
l'intérieur l'intelligence artificielle
c'est une des raisons pour laquelle on
développe ses technologies si avec que
des effets négatifs en vue on n'irait
pas dans cette direction
mon avis car il ya un potentiel
je parle souvent de l'ia de youtube en
particulier ma meilleure amie
si on réfléchit à ce que fait l'ia de
youtube aujourd'hui c'est que c'est déjà
très largement sur six enfin c'est plus
compliqué que ça bien sûr mais en
gohelle a vu toutes les vidéos youtube
c'est vrai que l sous titre
automatiquement les vidéos donc
capable de traduire en temps réel ou
prendre sémantique quelque part de ce
qui est dans les vidéos elle apprend le
profil de chaque utilisateur
il ya des milliards de profits d'humains
il qu il ya des milliards du grand rex à
ces aliments est pas capable de faire ce
à quoi est elle capable de recommander à
chaque humain une vidéo qui y est alors
plus ou moins perturbées km et gérard
avoir relativement pertinentes pour la
personne en question de tout ce travail
et c'est quelque chose il faudrait des
armes et des armes et des armes et du
vin pour pouvoir faire un travail
similaire
ces tirs de l'immeuble il se serait
temps en temps réel ouais bah non c'est
clair 50 on y prend ce il est gênant
système qui sont sur ma et d'une manière
générale quand quand tu n'y as bar un
être humain dans une tâche elle reste
imbattable
c'est le cas avec les échecs 1 les
échecs ses premiers vraiment cas
célèbres en tout cas de victoire d'une
machine sur un humain et jusqu'à ce jour
ben le champion du monde des échecs ce
sera plus jamais un être humain dans
l'histoire de l'humanité
c'est vrai avec le jeu de go ce sera
vrai avec eux depuis même avec votre jeu
et je pense que différents jeux atari
enfin chaque semaine finalement il ya
une équipe de chercheurs qui développe
une ia pour battre les humains à quelque
chose et il y arrivait reconnaissance
faciale ça devient de plus en plus de
cas reconnaissance audio du langage de
langage naturel
il arrive à écrire des articles
maintenant les systèmes open à yagg est
récemment sorti une ia
ils ont finalement pas osé la publier
parce que c'est un truc qui peut être
dangereux lorsque tu te retrouves avec
unia qui capable d'écrire un article
juste en se basant sur la première ligne
qui est écrite par un humain et en plus
le remplit le reste c'est la porte
ouverte aux ovnis osent encore plus le
dit fait que c'est un problème aussi qui
est il difficile à contrecarrer
lancement et aidez moi ya beaucoup de
comptes twitter qui sont tenus par des
bottes des
ouais les bottes il ya des vidéos
youtube qui sont clos dès qu'ils sont
conçus et plombé par des robots des
moteurs et l'oeil qui parle un peu de
tout ça pour sélective en savoir plus
donc là il ya beaucoup de dia qui sont
déjà parmi nous oui ça va en fait un
truc c'est normal que je m'étais fait du
cloud temps quand j'étais agri food
c'est quand on parle beaucoup de
concevoir une ia bénéfiques ou concevoir
unis à sécuriser ou imaginer on va voir
une irm pour la rend super intelligente
comme ça oui je réponds je vais attendre
ça assez peu parlé sur cette possibilité
il me semble que ce qui est plus
probable c'est qu'en fait on est des
systèmes qui sont déjà déployés dégâts
qui sont déjà parmi celles qu'ils ont
toujours dans l'iard de youtube par
exemple équivoque 6 ya juste pouvons
gagner gagner s'ils gagnent déjà en
capacité au fur et à mesure et peut-être
que c'est des il ya déjà des pots et qui
deviendront désir de coûts qui sont
capables ben ali hadji les youtube tente
enfin elle comprend déjà beaucoup
beaucoup de choses pour la même peau d
elle même ses propres vidéos dialoguer
avec avec les utilisateurs déjà elle
n'en spam certaines de certains certains
messages
elle censure certaines vidéos et saisi
avant petit à petit gagné les
compétences et devenir des yeux général
voir super intelligente
ouais donc ce serait oui c'est vrai
qu'il ya cette hypothèse qu en finale ce
serait une sorte de collection dia on
pourrait même imaginer internet devenir
conscient puisque finalement le le
jacques internet a déjà le contenu pour
apprendre tout ce qu'il faut pour
devenir une intelligence général il
suffit de lire wikipédia je dirais mais
ouais il ya ça pourrait après il ya
toujours le projet mais j'imagine que
une des clés pour l'ia général c'est la
capacité d'apprendre c'est un truc qu'on
a encore
on a réussi à plus ou moins faire en
sorte que les machines après une grasse
en machine learning par définition et le
diplôme ça mais ça nécessite quand même
une super superviser les données et
est-ce que c'est envisageable d'imaginer
une intelligence artificielle qui est
capable d'apprendre d'elle-même par
recherche
on recherche investigations est
d'arriver à des conclusions elle même
alors il n'ya qui fait des
investigations ça je pense que ça il ya
des concepts des gens machine landing
comme par exemple active learning qui
donc l'idée c'est l'acte iv ording sait
il va chercher à l'entv qu'en cdi à qui
interagissent avec des humains et il ya
chercher du bois posé la question qui
équipent elle nous permet d'avoir le
plus d'informations qu'il faisait un peu
comme ça qu'il ya des sites de fruits
mécanisme d'intervention ciel de machine
learning qui s'appelle notamment
l'attention
typiquement sur une image on en fait là
c'est un truc qui je pense aux abeilles
de plus en plus avec les déjà grossi de
plus en plus c'est soit dans une image
ou dans un texte souvent le gros de
l'image le gros du texte n'est pas
forcément ultra intéressant mais il ya
quelques trucs sur lequel il faut
réfléchir davantage d'une certaine
manière et sesia sont développés pour
passer plus de temps à analyser années
et plus en détail certains certains
morceaux d'image où certains certaines
parties d'un texte donc je pense que
petit à petit on se rapproche de chat et
on peut très bien imaginer youtube qui
va par exemple décortiqué beaucoup plus
une vidéo de plus dit pareil fait une
vidéo qu'à 50 millions de vues ou chose
comme ça une vidéo qui a trois vues bon
voilà l'annoncé sur ce qu'il ya beaucoup
d'eau et un contenu incroyable sur
youtube ouais je pense qu'on va
peut-être aussi voir de manière plus
futur proche c'est à dire au revoir
aussi des contenus générés
de plus en plus pas de dia on a vu que
nvidia s'est beaucoup de choses là
dessus que les graines donc
j'ai été bluffé de voir que il avait
réussi à générer des images de photos de
célébrités qui n'existe pas en fait
c'est juste sort de celia qui se dit
tiens ça c'est une célébrité qui
pourraient exister te sort un truc qu'il
photo réaliste en fait et tu dois et on
peut imaginer que le futur de jeux vidéo
pourrait être en partie lié à ça c'est à
dire les médias qui vont proposer des
décors qui ont proposé des débuts de
niveau tout à fait modéliser moment le
level designer il sera juste là en train
de dire oui je veux ça oui non je veux
pas ça donc ça sera une aide puisque
autre chose et pourquoi pas imaginer des
films entièrement créé par désir puisque
le taux d'ipp fait qu'elles sont
capables de créer des visages le
photoréalisme 3d aussi progresse de
manière exponentielle donc pourra
peut-être plus jamais me donner on
pourra que tu voir la différence entre
ce qui est généré par ordinateur et ce
qui est filmé même s'il a toujours mais
on est particulièrement bon à regarder
des visages humains
donc on est très facilement alertée
lorsqu'on on sent qu'il ya quelque chose
qui va pas ouais ça qu on appelait cela
on voit plus beaucoup plus d'image
photoréaliste de décor de salle ont même
de montagnes et de forêts plutôt que
d'être humains parce que l'être humain
on se dit ah non ça je vois bien que
c'est une machine qui là qu'il a généré
c'est un truc 3 direz vous c'est un
robot les robots d'ailleurs ccc la
vallée dérangeante est valide en langue
ce caniveau mais sans parvenir à ce que
vous faisiez sur le ce que donc le camp
jusqu'à et eye for good en fait il
beaucoup de avait résumé sa phrase en
anglais
ces jolies anglaises proglio en anglais
je suis désolé nous ceux qui aiment le
français mais du coup j'ai l'impression
que fargo il y avait beaucoup de
discours ce qui était sur mech
beneficial et eyes
et donc créer des désirs bénéfique et
c'est très cool et tout mais pour moi le
gros le défi ski fois ce sur quoi il
faudra voir plus travailler je pense que
c'est plus mais qu'elle ait bénéficié
c'est à dire rendre les yeux
d'aujourd'hui les neuf ans vous entendu
aujourd'hui bénéfique et du futur aussi
parce que notre puissance à avoir cette
posture où on va concevoir unia va bien
aller alors que il ya déjà plein dia et
je pense que c'est izia qui sont
déployés aujourd'hui dans aussi des
systèmes de recommandation en
particulier des liens de youtube six ans
c'est vraiment désiré ultra influentes
et qui est sur lequel il ya des
milliards de dollars investis fin c'est
vraiment là que ça se passe en termes de
termes de trafic et en termes de
l'influencé en termes d'argent et je
veux qu'il ya pas assez de réflexion ou
d'effort ou de discours qui parle de
rendre aux saisies en particulier
bénéfique
je pense que tu en penses tout à fait
raison on voit bien les problèmes qui
sont déjà généré sur le fait qu'il peut
y avoir des des billets de confirmation
il ya eu des cas de finalement des juges
qui demande d'adhésion ont requis des
mandats des systèmes artificiels de
d'établir des profils des détenus pour
savoir s'ils seront probables s'il est
probable finalement le taux de
probabilité qui vont être récidive
récidive récidiviste ans mais le
problème c'est que c'est basé sur des
données et ces données là ils sont
biaisés par des jugements ratio par
exemple le fait que en statistiques en
amérique statistiquement il ya plus de
personnes de couleurs qui vont
récidiviste qui vont être issus des
listes donc lhi alva elle va prendre en
compte ces données et ça donne un
résultat qui est biaisé et ça c'est un
problème on n'a pas envie de créer des
gars qui ont des erreurs qui ont les les
oies des erreurs humaines en fait mes
faiblesses de la de l'humain mais on a
aussi ses problèmes doigts de sa main
facebook twitter youtube leur algorithme
ils ont finalement compris d'une
certaine façon que
qui génère le plus de commentaires le
plus de réactions le plus de retweet
c'est tout ce qui est polémique tout ce
qui est controversé ait speech donc ils
vont mettre ça en avant beaucoup plus et
donc tu finis par enragé la communauté
internet ce qui s'est passé c'est une
des raisons pour laquelle j'ai pas je
passe beaucoup de temps sur les réseaux
sociaux
parce que je sais que je suis en moyenne
ils devoir plus des trucs qui vont
énervé ou des trucs qui est ce pour ça
aussi qu'il s'est passé par hasard que
les théories farfelues comme la terre
est plate soit populaire aujourd'hui
pile au moment où on a des youtube et
des plateformes comme ça qui permettent
de répandre des mauvaises idées à
travers le monde et qui sont encouragés
par des algorithmes qui sont les
algorithmes qui sont pas mauvais ou bon
intrasèquement ils font que répondre à
une sorte de l'optimisation des phases
très difficile il ya aussi le problème
de boîte noire finalement qu'on défend
on n'est même pas capable de savoir ce
qu'il ya derrière unia
je crois qu'il y avait eu un cas comme
ça avec amazon ou le amazon livraison à
un jour prime ils n'étaient pas
disponibles dans certaines dans certains
cas retiré et il se trouve que c'est des
quartiers noirs aux états unis est à new
york ou autre et du coup bas et
certaines personnes qui ont demandé à
lire amazon pour quoi le truc qui n'est
pas disponible dans le quartier là et
amazon n'est pas capable de réparer la
seule chose qui peut se dire c'est celia
cas des cibles et ça ça pose problème
voilà il ya parme dans le cas où tu veux
faire après soit à banque tombant qui
dit bon bain selon notre intelligence
artificielle
on a décidé de pas vous accorder après
toi tu dis pourquoi ils peuvent pas se
répandre
c'est la décision que l'intelligence
artificielle a pris selon vos données on
n'est pas capable de savoir exactement
quelles données et la prise mais selon
et il se trouve que tout de suite le
taux de recommandation dia est
supérieure à 70 % donc nous ont fait
confiance et toi tu te retrouve un peu
sur le cul parce que c'est ce que c'est
raciale est ce que c'est discriminatoire
ou du coi à ce sujet et statistique en
flammes sur ta chaîne et statistiques
femmes pour interviewer par hitler va
regarder
est-ce que moi sur ma chaîne ya 6,3 pour
cent de femmes derniers mois ok
j'imagine que votre chaîne doit être à
peu près pareil c'est quoi c'est un site
s'est insurgé pas sur ma chaîne dans les
analytics de youtube il ya des
statistiques a donc tu peux aller voir
vous allez voir ça et donc tu me dis que
6,3 pour cent des gens qui regardent mes
vidéos sont des femmes donc moi que je
vais boire et cc c'est extrêmement peu
et c'est beaucoup plus enfin beaucoup
moins que sur les autres plateformes et
tout ça c'est parce qu'il vous vend des
biens et tout ça mais ça serait sympa et
clermont en a bien assez inc
et je pense que c'est plus réfléchi si
plus je réfléchis plus je suis aperçu
qu'il servait empreinte de bialik aux
rythmiques il ya de youtube a juste
remarqué que les hommes sont peut-être
légèrement plus probable de cliquer sur
une vidéo de deux mètres au dessous du
genre et ajuste répliqué ce biais en
disant bon bah du coup je recommande
surtout à des hommes et ça fait des
finales de bulles et du coup parce que
aujourd'hui il ya 70% des vues sur
youtube qui sont recommandées par l'ia
de youtube
il y à du tube décide vraiment de ce que
les gens vont alors je pense que c'est
un peu moins pour des chaînes un peu
comme les nôtres sur 50 60 % hors
assurance je compte sur ma chaîne du
coup s'il ya des tubes veux que mes
vidéos ne survit que par les mecs elle
peut coincer
ouais c'est ça aussi on se rend pas
compte des scissions quel point les
filles ça renforce l'idée qu'on vit de
plus en plus dans des bus
un moment donné quand internet a
commencé à se répandre et que tout le
monde a eu un accident dix excès de v
c'était une sorte de nouveau village
village global où on ne pouvait
finalement interagir entre nous et
échanger des idées
finalement retrouvé une petite
communauté à l'échelle globale ce qui à
ce qui paraît génial mais en même temps
aujourd'hui on se rend compte que on est
nourri par l'information qui nous
plairait donc on n'est pas exposé aux
contres argument n'est pas exposé aux
débats on entretient notre propre ou à
nos propres arguments et nos propres
visions du monde qu'on ai donné mon
temps dans nos petites bulles c'est ça
aussi pour ça qu'il ya beaucoup de
jeunes exposés à des défauts débat c'est
à dire que et quelques arguments du côté
opposé qu'on veut c'est des caricatures
du côté opposé
c'est une renforce en fait en conduction
exactement il ya beaucoup de ce qu'est
ce que tu vois on a beau vous parler
d'intelligence artificielle mais sur sur
votre chaîne vous parle pas que de ça ce
qu'il ya d'autres sujets je trouve leurs
parts en a qui sont source de
préoccupation ou de d'entousiasme
potentiel le futur waouh iwuy forcément
préoccupations on peut on peut citer le
génie génétique
on a un petit peu parlé mais
effectivement l'idée qu'on n'entraîne
craquer le code de la vie est ce qu'on
va en faire
on sait pas trop on a la possibilité
encore une fois de guéret des maladies
d'augmenter notre espérance de vie mais
aussi de complètement transformé ce qui
est là ce qu'on construit les trous mais
aujourd'hui pourrait changer
on sait pas quel point on doit modifier
et c'est aussi la question finalement et
de philosophique de la science
10 kg est et la philosophie inédit ce
qu'on doit faire mais ça devient
compliqué parce que là maintenant là les
généticiens les chercheurs on y a
les scientifiques ont désormais des
outils techniques qui font que c'est
sérieux de se poser les questions
philosophiques désormais donc c'est
important qu'ils aient un bagage
j'irai à l'éthique mais ouais ça c'est
un sujet défini génétique mais j'ai
l'impression que c'est un peu inévitable
a été corrigé là il ya eu un
développement incroyable ans dans le
décodage du génome ont finalement ça
c'est un bon exemple aussi de décollage
rapide d'une certaine façon puisque en
l'espace de quelques quelques années et
décennies à peine on est passé d'un coup
monumental pour séquencer le génome
humain aujourd'hui quelques centaines
d'euros je pense et je pense que dans je
pense dans une décennie ou deux chaque
être humain qui sera née aura son adn
ses pensées et ses sera une sorte de
d'albums génétique pour savoir s'il a
des prédispositions maladie tout ça
c'est une bonne chose
maintenant la question de savoir la
question éthique et le débat qui
commence à naître est ce que les parents
doivent choisir si leur enfant sera
grand aura les yeux bleus ou un brin
ouvert et finalement la sq il aura une
masse musculaire plus importante et qui
finit par entrer dans la petit à petit
dans la porte de l'eugénisme et sa wii
débat éthique monstrueux après j'ai
l'impression que c'est un peu juste si
on si on a des ambitions de colonisation
spatiale le génie génétique ce sera un
outil
du battoir puisque faut voir à quel
point l'être humain est fait pour vie
sur terre et par ailleurs c'est un peu
ça ça me fait un peu rire quand on parle
de ces de l'intelligent design dont
parle de l'univers imaginé que l'univers
a été spécialement conçu avec nous en
tête
c'est oublier que notre ère 19 19% de
l'univers il n'est pas du tout viable
pour les trains à gré moi je pense pas
vraiment en eux mais je pense qu'on
devra modifier notre code génétique et
peut-être pour vivre sur mars il faudra
être plus capable d'absorber la
radiation il d'ailleurs je sais pas donc
ça ouais c'est ça une des catégories
importantes qui sont en train de
façonner le façonner le futur
bon on peut ajouter aussi le la conquête
spatiale
donc le monde mon conquête peut-être pas
vraiment dans le besoin mais plus
l'exploration
ça me semble inévitable je pense qu'on
va faire des percées dans le coup de dés
lancement on en train de voir que sa
chute et la lune
ensuite en aura mars puis une grande
chance qu'on finisse par explorer les
lunes de jupiter et de saturne
il ya la cybernétique la robotique qui
sont des sujets fascinants aussi puisque
ça touche un peu liga mais en même temps
lorsque la robotique comme un sujet
assez différent puisque on peut tout
simplement créer une coquille vide n'est
pas obligé de lui donner noté jean
tissier les ça n'empêche qu'il ya des
débats qui soulève sera quel point on
veut que nos une qu'arbore android soit
ressemblant à l'humain pourquoi on a
cette envie finalement de répliquer
d'humains on voit au japon notamment
iliad et certains des robots les plus
réalistes au monde son sens au japon et
c'est intéressant de par sa culture là
s'approprier la robotique puisqu'ils ont
une relation particulière avec les
robots ouais ils craignent pas du tout
nous révoltent ils essaient de tout ça
en tête
les proches des robots et
bien ça c'est pas du tout peur ouais je
pense qu'ils ont aussi la conscience que
c'est probablement le futur du japon
puisque leur population vieillit et ils
ont besoin de main d'oeuvre donc ils
sont que j'ai aussi d'innover là dedans
et il ya des choses assez spécial au
japon qui se passe il ya des omd l'une
des maisons closes entièrement peuplée
par des robots sexuelle on va dire ça
c'est ça passerait pas en france pensent
comme comme mesure donc lé japonisant
une relation assez particulière que les
robes hommes c'est aussi en partie parce
qu'ils ont une une tradition religieuse
qui finalement ils ont cette idée que
les objets peuvent avoir une âme et ses
objets inanimés peut finalement avoir
une naissance donc un robot soit peut
très bien être vivant entre guillemets
ça n'empêche pas pour eux ils ont tous
peur l'association fait penser que
j'étais une conférence une fois avec une
présentation d'une chercheuse de haïti
sur des robots utilisés jusqu au seti
robots pour mersa sionnel pour utiliser
pour des maisons de retraite pour
notamment rappelé aux personnes âgées de
prendre tel ou tel médicament suivre
mais également du coup les accompagner
toujours un jour et interagir avec eux
et enfin des conclusions ils avaient
déployé ça et puis conclusion me vois
c'est que les personnages et c'était
vraiment attachés aux robots aux états
unis du coup la chercheuse était très le
bilan était sont des traits positifs
produits ti charisme
ça s'est très très bien d'un point de
vue médical c'est très bien tout ça mais
du coup un certain moment j'ai parlé
avec un autre français qui est qui et
qui était là et lui étaient horrifiés à
cette idée quand ils lisent et c'est
juste horrible l'accompagnement humain
disparaît on laisse toujours au beau
gosse comme ça et qu'il ya vraiment un
choc culturel je pense que japon est
vraiment une extrême d'un côté je pense
à la france et pas mal loin dans un
extrême de l'autre côté
des états y sont peut-être un peu plus
au milieu ouais y'a un peu large et un
peu techno technophobie ciments français
mais bon c'est pas je pense qu'il ya pas
de jugement là dessus c'est juste faut
un peu de tout quoi pour faire
maintenant dire et je pense que c'est
bien c'est bien d'être méfiant sur la
technologie je pense que on aurait dû
être plus méfiant sur les réseaux
sociaux
parce qu'on en paye un peu le prix
aujourd'hui ce qu'on est devenus des
techno addict et internet finalement si
c'est assez intéressante à gratter de
l'évolution d'internet puisque c'était
vraiment quelque chose qui a été c'est
tout s'approprie internet une certaine
façon il ya eu des jets des géants
évidemment si on qui ont émergé mais où
on n'a jamais vraiment eu notre mot à
dire
ça va m'aider à jamais été vraiment une
un choix démocratique qu'est ce que va
être internet
on a un peu été baigné dedans ça a été
une évolution sans vraiment savoir ce
que ça allait donner puis aujourd'hui on
en est où on en est il ya des bénéfices
des sap a été planifiée certes pas été
réfléchie c'est non effectivement la
bassée a été créée comme moi partager de
l'information universitaire je crois est
venu c'est devenu stock c'est important
d'avoir des histoires de forum public
sur certains sur certaines choses comme
après toujours cette idée est ce que on
a vraiment
est ce qu'on a vraiment le choix de
d'orienter les décisions politiques et
les entreprises sur les technologies ce
que se fait pas contre
enfin malgré nous on va dire mais
justement je pense qu'au niveau de l'ia
si c'est pas peu réfléchie et planifiée
je pense que ça va mal se passer et il
n'y a conçu de façon organique sont sans
préparer le futur macé
ça me paraît être très très très
dangereux ouais [ __ ] c'est la même
chose pour la génétique exactement après
j'ai l'impression que la communauté de
la génétique
c'est quand même beaucoup plus mobilisés
j'ai l'impression exemple dans les
années 70 avait eu des conférences et il
ya eu des traités internationaux
donc aujourd'hui par l'amp le clonage
humain
jusqu'à preuve du contraire ça n'a
jamais été fait pourtant la technologie
on avait qu'on a cloné des des animaux
on a tourné des chiens est d'amener des
produits fins même 10 h peut-être je ne
sais pas ce qu'en l'âge avec alone et
d'être humains donc il ya eu quand même
des pressions internationales pour que
ça n'arrive pas et c'est une bonne chose
puisque je pense que c'est pas
souhaitable pour le futur de l'humanité
c'est un exemple plutôt positif moi
sinon je pense qu'un autre un autre
point où on aborde souvent sur la chaîne
et flers et tout ce qui est lié à
l'énergie
on peut le dire est que cette énergie
c'est au final la clé pour un futur
la clé du futur je dirais presque prêt
je suis pas ce plaisir du cellier
précieux ouais c'est difficile de savoir
qui va venir en premier mais bien que
l'énergie c'est on ne peut pas faire
sans un et c'est un peu la clé pour une
utilisation de type 1 sur l'échelle de
garda chef c'est à dire sur une échelle
d'utilisation énergétique d'une
civilisation et on voit bien qu'on peut
pas faire sans une énergie propre et
renouvelable
parce que ça crée des conditions
extrêmes sur la planète qui sont plus
viables sur le long terme
et du coup et trouver une source
alternative d'énergie sur son énergie
abondante beaucoup plus abondantes même
qu'est ce qu'on a aujourd'hui puisqu'il
va falloir
encore plus d'énergie je pense que la
fusion nucléaire semble être l'énergie
la plus qui répond à tous les critères
quoi beaucoup plus la faire ouais faut
réussir je pense comment il ya des
projets il ya le projet iter en est de
la france où c'est en train de
construire un prototype de réacteur à
fusion nucléaire qui est prévu pour
générer l'électricité donc d'être sur un
ratio positif c'est-à-dire en générer de
l'électricité qu'il en consomme aux
alentours de 2030 2035 et donc ça ça
peut ouvrir la porte à vraiment ce que
l'énergie c'est la clé pour c'est la clé
pour site permet d'ouvrir toutes les
portes pour la suite
en termes de d'abondance c'est à dire
que on a besoin d'eau on vit sur une
planète rempli d'eau mais on peut pas la
boire c'est con donc il faut trouver un
moyen de la des salines commander sa way
enlever le céleri des fois c'est donc
fausse route en moyenne dans le ville
celle de l'honorable sali l'eau de mer
c'est un processus qui est gourmand en
énergie
mais si on avait une énergie abondante
et est propre ben on règle ses problèmes
ensuite la chaîne black enfin la
nourriture on peut avoir des fermes
verticales un peu tout ça ça demande de
l'énergie oreilles on a besoin d'énergie
donc si on a une source d'énergie
abondante comme la fusion est clair
c'est un truc qui finalement c'est comme
une sorte de d'arborescence quoi c'est
la racine c'est l'énergie ensuite toutes
les branches permettent de faire un
arbre qui soit majestueux donc ça ça
peut être le futur tel que je l'imaginé
tels que je l'espère en tout cas
la fusion est pas le solaire ne
suffirait pas non non moi le problème
c'est que bon le solaire ça aussi pour
créer des panneaux solaires sa demande
de devenir sourds ça peut aussi
vous avez des problèmes sur les terres
rares et il ya aussi le fait que bon
faut quand même court et enfin il ya
déjà eu des études de fait sur combien
de panneaux solaires il faudrait pour
que la terre soit complètement dépendant
des panneaux solaires
c'est pas tant que ça je veux dire c'est
pas à couvrir toute l'europe par exemple
s'est vu recouvrir une petite portion
d'un désert
après il ya le problème de distribution
d'énergie ce qui ça veut dire avoir des
câbles électriques partout donc
l'énergie solaire le problème c'est les
stockages du tout ouais le stockage
aussi c'est un problème
bon on voit qu'il ya des progrès qui
sont qui sont fait l'acte sur ce domaine
royal et renouvelables en général c'est
du très bonne solution l'éolien la
géothermie hydraulique et le solaire et
puis l'homme biomasse aussi mais je
pense qu'on a besoin d'un ce qui est ce
qu'il a appelé un mix énergétique au
final c'est à dire un ensemble de
solutions et la fusion nucléaire c'est
un peu la cerise sur le gâteau puisque
il ya c'est beaucoup beaucoup vers
quasiment aucun point négatif sur le
fait d'utiliser la fission nucléaire il
n'y a aucun risque d'accident puisque le
truc qui s'est ainsi un problème il n'y
a pas d'explosion quoi il ya pas de
radiations nucléaires
il n'y a pas de déchets il suffit juste
de l'eau en fait pour faire marcher le
film claire et des ressources très
abondante et ça produit beaucoup
d'énergie donc c'est le saint graal
non vous mettrez ouais j'ai fait un
podcast récemment avec un ingénieur en
énergie
il sortira pas sortir sur la chaîne dans
deux semaines je crois et on parle un
petit peu de l'affinité abandonné donc
c'est intéressant d'avoir son point de
vue on est très très précis sur la
science puisque c'est un événement est
donc en tout cas on en a déjà réussi à
dans quelques secondes voire quelques
minutes je vois que le record du monde
c'est quelques minutes à maintenir la
fusion nucléaire sur terre mais
faut apprendre à le faire de plus donc
on sait que c'est possible on sait que
c'est faisable d'agir le soleil c'est
comme ça qui marche
d'une certaine façon l'avenue clair
c'est de l'énergie solaire la presse ce
que je peux comprendre que la fusion on
veut faire dans le réacteur de fusion
nucléaire est quelqu'un de très
différent de la fusion dont le sol et
les crises financières il dégage pas
beaucoup d'énergie ouais c'est le conte
va faire sur terre potentiellement un
pupille cela nécessite aussi plus de
chaleur et ouais en fait la différence
c'est la durée puisque l'énergie
nucléaire du soleil si je dis pas de
conneries enfin l'énergie de la fim est
claire elle prend des milliards d'années
et finalement à se faire nous font face
à bly de quoi sacré défi technique
ouais c'est un défi technique mais bon
bout d'un moment on a fait des choses
c'est remarquable à la nôtre histoire
aller sur la lune par exemple construire
des des structures très grosses comme
l'art l'a lâchée à genève s'est excusé
qu'est-ce qui me manquerait pour la
fusion nucléaire quelques lots les deux
personnes qui est toujours en dressage
et une amie qui travaille sur des trucs
plus de fusion nucléaire
ces gens reconnaissent zone friqués qui
manque c'est une bonne question
allemande est effectivement parce que
bon il ya déjà le fait que sa
reconstruction on conte programme du
temps à construire
et puis on n'est pas sûr aussi comment
stabiliser la la réaction en fait il
faut du plasma qui est chauffée je crois
à 150 millions de gré à gré il faut
maintenir ce plasma dans un dans une
sorte de cylindre il ya plusieurs formes
et voilà ça pose de problèmes techniques
on s'est vraiment enfin sa demande aussi
de l'énergie donc faut réussir à générer
plus énergique on en dépense pour faire
la fusion nucléaire et la belge les
prototypes plus que des avancées
récentes par la prière
ouais c'est une bonne question je pense
que c'est impossible parce que l'ia
pourrait peut-être aider à développer
[Musique]
une architecture pour la centrale qui
pourrait être optimisé qu'est ce que tu
veux un site si lui des difficultés
c'est de maintenir le truc en équilibre
s'imaginent que les grosses difficultés
du coup si la agir en temps réel et
s'adapter en temps réel à des
perturbations qu'on observe dans les
mesures à tout ça et ça c'est
typiquement un truc que tu n'y a point
apprendre à faire je sais moi et c'est
vrai que c'est une possibilité il faudra
se renseigner plus en détail avec des
gens qui sont peut-être en relation avec
des ingénieurs qui travaillent sur le
projet notamment de la france une des
bonnes nouvelles sur la fusion nucléaire
je dirais que c'est qu'il ya le secteur
du privé qui commencent à s'y intéresser
et pas par hasard puisque la première
entreprise qui va réussir à créer une
centrale nucléaire à fusion sera riche
et gros investissements la der garde
côtes en ciel exactement il suffit de
regarder les uns parmi les entreprises
les plus riches
historiquement il ya eu l'énergie le
secteur de l'énergie est premier les
rockefeller par exemple aux états unis
c'était des investisseurs dans le
pétrole allegro entreprises
d'aujourd'hui qui y voit là le chef des
compagnies donc il ya fort à parier que
voilà la première entreprise qui sera
capable de développer commercialement la
fusion nucléaire sera multi hiver
peut-être c'est pas moi en tout cas
c'est pour ça qu'il ya des motivations
financières derrière ça développe une
compétition saine
finalement pour développer peut-être
plus vite que prévu plus vite qu'en tout
cas que si que les gouvernements les
coopérations des agences internationales
qui s'unissent comment comme on le voit
avec finalement le secteur des roquettes
des fusées
avec spécialistes et blue origin qui ont
accéléré et finalement la réutilisation
des boosters effet possible plus et
moins cher d'aller dans l'espace donc ça
engendre une nouvelle ère une nouvelle
course seulement à l'espace donc c'est
bénéfique une compétition saine espérant
qu'on voit ici avec la fusion nucléaire
ça serait ça serait cool fissionner
guerre tu penses rsa bat la fission
c'est un peu un problème sur le long
terme parce que il faut bien se dire que
les déchets nucléaires en lisant terre
et on nous enterre à des endroits où
voilà rien on fait vraiment en sorte
qu'on les enterre là où ils seront
jamais des théories potentiellement est
toujours un risque évidemment mais
j'arrive sur le court terme l'énergie
nucléaire la fission nucléaire elle est
en plus les centrales d'aujourd'hui ils
sont beaucoup plus sûr on a appris de
l'aider des erreurs qu'on a eues avec
les accidents comme tchernobyl
kojima donc je pense que c'est une
énergie qui est tout à fait utile et
d'ailleurs la france la france quand
même un très faible empreinte carbone
comparé à d'autres pays en grande partie
grâce à l'utilisation de l'énergie
nucléaire qui fait qu' on a une
électricité pas cher est relativement
propre
donc quand paris là je suis en australie
c'est tout l'inversé l'australie pour il
du charbon parce qu'ils ont énormément
dans leur sous sol ils ont aucun aucune
motivation vraiment un faire autrement
autrement pourtant il ya du soleil en
australie et semblerait que bon ça va
venir mais apparaît aussi un peu de la
culture attendait vers l'arctique a dû
expliquer un peu ce que c'est oui tout à
fait ferme verticale c'est l'idée de
traditionnellement l'agriculture on voit
ça comme des chants dans la voilà dans
la campagne il faut un sol fertile puis
il faut du soleil et arrosez très
souvent pour avoir dit les champs de blé
ou autre
mais en fait il est tout à fait possible
d'obtenir le résultat similaire dans un
hangar en gare avec des lumières
artificielles un système d'irrigation
artificielle avec exactement le bon
nombre de nutriments pour que les
plantes soit prospère et tu finis par à
créer des conditions idéales pour avoir
des légumes et des fruits sur des
conditions artificielles
ce qui fait que c'est une solution pour
nourrir le monde tout à fait viable
notamment pour on pourrait imaginer
avoir des fermes verticales hors des
grands centres urbains dans des grandes
villes on pouvait voir des immeubles
entiers qui sont dédiés à l'agriculture
verticale ce qui fait tu enlèves le
transport de l'équation
donc c'est bon pour la planète à des
produits plus frais qui vont être
distribués localement ça me semble être
après il ya toujours des réactions
négatives et toujours des gens qui
disent non c'est pas bio c'est pas cette
idée que si ça a été produit dans un sol
fertile quelquefois dans une belle
région
c'est ça je pense que on fait beaucoup
d'erreurs avec cette idée d naturels et
artificiels
ouais aujourd'hui est un pur on sait
surtout qu'il ya un champ d'agriculture
s'est absolument pas naturel c'est ça
c'est ça d'être une forêt pour pouvoir
faire ça que ouais la nature ne ferai
jamais un truc monoclonaux culture comme
ça n'existe pas dans la nature un champ
de blé
c'est impossible il ya que le d'être
humain qui est capable de planter que la
même chose aura pris à la permaculture
qui est inverse finale et c'est la
nature finalement travaillé comme elle
le fait dans la de manière normale
naturelle
c'est à dire avoir un rosier avec un
côté un prunier qui va retravailler
ensemble tu nourris l'ensemble moi je
parle en expert en art culture mais
jacques la permaculture celle inverse de
la monoculture d'une certaine façon est
et même et être capable de faire 1 mise
à l'échelle de la permaculture pour
nourrir le monde ça ressemble s'assemble
aujourd'hui extrêmement un peu probable
je miserai plus sur les fermes
verticales
surtout que le rendement et la qualité
aussi du produit finalement élevé tu vas
les par avoir un truc qui a pas de
pesticides machin est dans un
environnement complètement contrôlé et
intègre évidemment ce que tu peux avoir
en terme de surface parce que je pense
que exactement le gros problème des
agriculteurs c'est que ça prend beaucoup
de surface et du coup cette surface et
c'est pas de la forêt et du coup on va
se concentrer sur un bâtiment ça prend
beaucoup moins de place exactement plus
en plus il me semble que les ratios sont
impressionnants sur un hangar de bateau
qui part en guerre de bateaux et un
conteneur
tu peux tu peux avoir une production qui
est l'équivalent d'un champ de quelques
hectares il ya aussi des économies d'eau
monstrueuse puisque je crois c'est 90%
d'économie d'eau un système artificiel
ce que ben tu ne te donne exactement ce
que la plante a besoin plutôt que
d'arroser à l'aveuglette comme ça ouais
donc la sillage il est maximisée
minimiser ses voix par contre ce que
j'ai vu deux des fermes verticales j'ai
pas beaucoup cherchent cdc beaucoup sur
des choix des fruits ou des dvd mais est
ce que les joueurs y aider tu peux faire
du blé ou du dieu rit comme ça on est
ferme verticale et j'ai pas vraiment ça
je vous avoue que je crois pas qu'il ya
eu des tentatives encore ce que serait
comme tu dis j'ai vu aussi beaucoup de
laitue beaucoup de mal midi tomates
et des fruits mais sur le principe je
pense que c'est tout à fait possible
après ce avec la plante un champ de blé
ça prend de la place dans un hangar ce
tout à fait imaginable à voir après tout
il suffit d'avoir 1 1
une sorte de sol des fertilisants et de
l'eau et puis du soleil artificiel et
puis la machine devrait pousser
voilà l'impression que j'avais pour
l'instant mais je me trompe peut-être
c'est secteur en fait c'est pour des
raisons plus économique parce que fois
le riz et le blé coûtent tellement pas
cher que c'est difficile de mettre en
compétition avec et en plus ça tombe
bien c'est vrai que je pense qu'il
faudra beaucoup plus de motivation enfin
il faudra d'autres d'autres facteurs
pour faire en sorte qu'on fasse de notre
culture vertical
après je pense que l'agriculture et ical
de blé et ça mais au final c'est les
produits peut-être les plus chers qu'on
a envie de faire en agriculture
verticale je pense que voilà et aussi de
donner un peu plus de logique sur la
consommation alimentaire de produits
c'est-à-dire qu'aujourd'hui est ce que
c'est vraiment logique de manger un
avocat qui va du mexique alors que si
une serre verticale peut le produire
dans ta ville ça serait serait mieux
pour la planète pour le fait qu' on
arrête les transports comme ça de
produits qui viennent de l'autre bout du
monde
c'est génial de manger des tomates en
hiver mais c'est pas vraiment la façon
dont la nature est produit la tomate
donc on est obligé d apporter du maroc
ou de chez padoue et en agriculture
verticale les saisons ne compte pas
puisque tu peux faire ça en 24 heures
sur 24 sept jours sur sept toute l'année
pas d'hiver donc voir des tomates tout
le temps et je pense que c'est plutôt
ces ingrédients là qui vont être
favorisé les pros au niveau agriculture
on peut aussi parler de l'agriculture
li bétail qui représentent quasiment
autant en émissions de gaz à effet de
serre que les transports et ça c'est pas
rassurant quand on voit que le monde se
développent les pays en voie de
développement généralement ski ceux qui
cherchent à faire c'est manger de la
viande et la plupart des champs qui sont
plantés aujourd'hui il faut en fait ils
vont être destinés à être mangés par des
peurs du bétail des vaches notamment des
biscuits secs et des burgers donc une
alternative c'est la viande in vitro
dont j'ai parlé aussi dans une des
vidéos sur l'agriculture
voilà je suis à fond dedans parce que je
suis végétarien personnellement pour des
questions éthiques et écologiques puis
aussi pour ma santé mais j'ai absolument
aucun problème de manger un bifteck et
des cultivées en laboratoire puisque ça
me semble être ça me semble être une
solution logique tu prends des cellules
d'une bête et tullaye reproduit dans une
culture et tu finis avec un steak
or aujourd'hui on sait faire des ces
cachets à dire puisque c'est la viande
la plus facile à recréer puisque c'est
juste un ensemble dessus ces mots c'est
pas y'a pas de maire il ya pas de
muscles et voilà il ya eu des tests qui
ont été faits le coude le coût de
création d'un hamburger a diminué
pareille date d'un facteur énorme qui
fait qu'aujourd'hui ça coûte 10 10 10
balles en fait d'avoir un nombre de
regrets donc là les seuls les obstacles
aujourd'hui c'est les régulations c'est
des tests sur la santé des donc je pense
que d'ici quelques années on va voir ça
dans les supermarchés et on va commencer
à voir ça on est dans les fast food on
aura le choix entre boeuf traditionnelle
et 2 artificielle et on se dira bombe à
comparer puis petit à petit je pari est
un pari personnel je serais probablement
pas là pour le voir mais carrément donné
dans notre histoire dans le futur
un mois jeu rapide de bêtes aujourd'hui
on aura un problème on sera probablement
critiquer notre époque sera critique est
assez sévèrement par le fait qu'on a
industrialisé la la traite des animaux
de façon un pas du tout se préoccuper de
leur bien-être donc squatter la lfuq le
futur des animaux il est il est
bénéfique ouais travail est un sujet qui
arrive souvent qui revient souvent
j'imagine ces sujets des inégalités est
ce que tu penses que ces généralités
effectivement il ya cette idée que on
voit bien aujourd'hui que le monde il ya
plus des modalités que jamais par le
passé
donc c'est aussi parce qu'il ya plus de
monde donc forcément le ratio il est lé
plus gros mais les riches n'ont jamais
été aussi riches et les pauvres n'ont
jamais été aussi riches également donc
ça va dans les deux sens je pense que le
monde globalement sans riches il n'y a
pas à chier mais c'est tellement il ya
un écart qui c'est qu'a grandi et il ya
un risque quand même certains scénarios
du futur
par exemple si on prend le génie
génétique une idée qui revient c'est que
peut-être qu'il y aura une égalité
finalement façon génie génétique qui
fait qu'il aura qu'une classe d'élite
riches qui aura accès à la santé
parfaite l'immortalité entre guillemets
biologique tout cas la longévité et que
le reste de la population sera laissée
voilà comme aujourd'hui confinement on
aura une santé moyennes et vivra une vie
mais je pas si c'est vraiment crédit
puisque au final tu vois j'ai un
téléphone c'est un smartphone il est à
peu près le même que l'homme le plus
riche du monde
l'accès à la technologie il s'est fait
quand même de manière assez latéral
n'est pas sur une sorte de pyramide où
les riches ont
ont toutes les technologies et nous on
n'a rien il ya quand même un transfert
alors après c'est sûr qu'en général les
gens qui ont plus d'argent sont en bonne
santé puisque c'est un des meilleurs
soins mais c'est voilà on est quand même
donné on n'est pas à plein j'irai mais
effectivement le dissident dans l'ia le
l'hypothèse que vraiment les
développements l'intelligence
artificielle vont bénéficier massivement
des petites régions du monde
c'est en ça valait ou à l'est de la
chine shenzhen et que ça va enrichir
certaines personnes de manière vraiment
incroyable et il y aura un manque de
redistribution et d'une manière générale
j'ai quand même envie j'ai l'impression
quand même qu'il y aura des tentatives
qui vont être proposées
tout simplement parce qu'on n'aura pas
le choix pour redistribuer je pense
notamment où le revenu universel du bail
l'universal basic income ou en fait
l'idée c'est c'est guy tendance actuelle
de tomates isation de certaines tâches
d'activité professionnelle qui forcément
entraîné un licenciement puisque si une
machine est capable de faire ton boulot
de meilleur que toi avec le rapid qui
finit par tuer vraiment être nécessaire
donc résultat chômage
mais si ça se multiplie à l'échelle d'un
pays de manière drastique
il y aura un problème forcément il y
aura soit des révoltes soit gouvernement
sera pas capable de maintenir un système
économique viable ou je sais pas donc
une idée c'est de redistribuer les
revenus tous les mois par exemple de
1000 euros ou quelque chose comme ça
n'importe et à toutes les personnes qui
ont plus de 18 ans c'est un peu près
l'idée peu importe ce que tu fais peu
importe où tu as déjà un boulot au peu
importe si tu n'as pas ta une sorte de
c2c un peu à filet social de sécurité
août à au moins de quoi nourrir au moins
de quoi être le g au moins de quoi
soigner dans les cas les plus graves
et je pense qu'on me donne rage parce
qu'il ya déjà eu des tentatives ou en
finlande je crois qu'ils ont fait un
test sur
petite portion de la population en
alaska ils ont un truc similaire qui
redistribue l'argent du pétrole ou
personnes qui vivent en alaska et ça se
passe très bien puisqu'il voyais bien
que la criminalité est en baisse
blessé depuis ce système là il voit bien
que l'éducation augmenté
l'entrepreneuriat aussi donc
après il ya toujours des gens qui vont
dire non donner de l'argent gratuit ces
communistes ou c ceci dit socialiste
critique mais sur le papier ce qu'on a
d'autres options à suivre est une chose
qui me rassure c'est que les les avocats
du 2 du revenu universel ce qui le met
en avant le plus c'est généralement les
millionnaires du la silicon valley
c'est les milliardaires même elon musk
est favorable jeff bezos c'est favorable
et les fondateurs de google sont
favorables me semble même que mark
zuckerberg
donc voilà il ne restait pas des ses
palais c'est pas des pics ou quoi c'est
pas des caricatures des vilains riches
qui dirigent le monde parce qu'ils ont
quand même l'intention de faire en sorte
que qu'on distribue bill gates il a
donné la montée de la force de sa
fortune
il ya des entreprises en fait d'élire à
des associations caritatives et il fait
beaucoup de choses aujourd'hui de façon
c'est un philanthrope ce type qu'est-ce
qui fait c'est aider notamment en
afrique
donc certes il ya des inégalités mais je
pense que il ya aussi des bons côtés
dans le fait que les gens qui ont
énormément d'argent aujourd'hui
cherchent à aider
après a voir comment ça va évoluer
je pense que c'est à une perspective sur
cette question s'il je suis très
favorable universel également et en
effet c'est intéressant c'est que les
riches soient est très riche soit elles
sont en faveur de sa est aimé par contre
est-ce que j'ai commencé à entendre
parler de cette histoire de revenu
universel on peut en 2012 2013 comme ça
une époque où c'était
peu connu et quand j'en parlais
l'arrivée en gare d avec des gros yeux
c'était c'est n'importe quoi
j'ai trouvé ça fou à quel point c'était
devenu quasiment mainstream en 2010
c'est tout vous dire cette vie c'est toi
y'a même un candidat à l'élection
présidentielle en france qui en a parlé
j'ai l'impression que depuis 2010 est
c'est un petit peu perdues des radars
j'entends moi parler quoi je passe alors
si vous aussi
ouais c'est possible mais je sais qu'il
ya un candidat aux états unis l'a
quittée -qui ceux qui se présentent pour
les élections en 2005 qui est way andrew
yang ouais c'est un héros sont son aja
façon sa campagne à les orienter là
dessus que si on va mettre en place le
billard aux états unis et y
c'est un des rares sapin c'est la
première fois que j'entends un candidat
alors une présidence peu importe
laquelle qui met en avant les la
disruption technologique donc ça c'est
intéressant pour ça je pense que c'est
quelqu'un m'en faut pas arriver je pense
pas qu'ils vont être élus mais ce serait
intéressant que certaines des 6 10 soit
pris en compte si doux si c'est si c'est
un candidat démocrate qui remporte cette
élection là bas parce que là il n'est
pas encore candidat à la présidentielle
il est candidat à la primaire on va voir
comment ça évolue et tout ça mais ouais
c'est donc si j'étais enfant je t'envoie
10 ans en 2015 j'aurai dit droite a eu
énormément de temps avant que qu'il est
le revenu universel
bon peut-être dix ans on va dire et puis
par contre lorsqu'il commence à avoir
les élections fin 2010 cet avis est
vraiment pour bientôt pour des grands
des grandes nations
et puis la petite a dit j'ai
l'impression qu'ils aient art c'est
peut-être lié aussi à la polarisation
idéologique fait qu'ils aient d'autres
sujets qui soit plus mis en avant
on fait que j'ai l'impression que ça
puisse retarder enfin rendu un peu plus
pessimistes sur quand est ce qu'on va
voir
je pense qu'on finira par y arriver mais
ça s y avait un pari je reste en 2006
avec paris ça je vais parler que macron
pascal revenu universel
plus de 50% des de probabilités mais moi
ça c'est un petit peu diminué depuis
ouais ça va être compliqué je pense que
c'est quand les prochaines des actions
sur 2020 la france france et 2022 ah
ouais ouais c'est 2017 2022 c'est moins
5 ans en france et en asie ni 2016 2020
je suis complètement coupé du bois un
petit peu intéressants les maillots et
maquereau est réélu et qu'il passe le
revenu vers celle je gagne à paris
ouais c'est vrai que ça semble compliqué
parce que faut savoir qu'il ya une sorte
de résistance à cette idée par là il
parler j'en prenais pour le peuple
j'avais je crois que c'est la suisse
d'ailleurs confère un référendum se
tuent ils ont à vue ouais mais la raison
lorsque j'ai compris en tout cas c'est
que i les riches en fallait et les
suisses ont trahi le revenu universel
qui proposait c'était 2400 francs par
mois jusqu à peu près au choix des 1200
euros hélas comme ça ils sont vaillants
et en fait les suisses ne sont pas que
ce n'était pas assez
désolé c'est [ __ ] de la gueule du
monde wally cette planète
ouais c'est vrai que j'ai pas s'ils sont
concernés
bon tout cas soit qu'un brouillon aux
états unis propose mille dollars par
mois et il sait très bien que ces teams
en mille dollars par mois ses limites
pour quelqu'un qui a une famille ou quoi
mais bon après c'est chaque membre de la
famille entre guillemets par les enfants
c'est quand même une différence la fin
d'année ses 12000 ça permet d'avoir
quand même
une sorte de sécurité quoi tu ta
s'attend certainement coin tu sais que
tu peux en cas de coup dur
ça permet aussi de prendre plus de
risques sur les décisions que tu fais
dans ta carrière si tu veut démissionner
parce que tu sais que tu peux peut-être
trouvé mieux
voilà ça peut être aussi un une
motivation pour les gens de d'entre eux
comptent peut-être de se lancer en tant
que youtube heures ouais mais ça c'est
un argument pour du coup enfin c'est un
argument fréquence c'est ça fluidifie
réel argument d'économie ça plus
différer le marché de l'emploi
ça permettrait d'avoir une meilleure
allocation des emplois des gentils qui
serait plus contents de ce qu'ils font
et il démissionnerait s'il n'aime pas ce
qu'ils font et du coup les emplois par
exemple qui qui sont chiants va
typiquement même s'ils sont simples ils
sont chiants personne ne veut les faire
des sous quand même super parce que les
gens sont obligés de travailler mais ça
ça ferait que les prix les salaires
seraient plus élevés pour ces emplois-là
retrouverez un peu l'équipe de marché et
une super vidéo 2h15 passerelle ski qui
parle de tout ça quand j'étais ok les
souhaits pascal et d'autres prennent que
tu d'autres sujets que à mettre en avant
selon je pense conclure petit à petit
wen staff et je pense que on a fait on a
fait une bonne bonne session à une
conversation sur le futur en général sur
plein de sujets j'aime bien traité et
donc c'était sympa tout cas pas de
problème d'un concert face à je devrais
pas aussi d'inviter sur un podcast sur
la chaîne de flers 26 quand je t'ai
traité de l'année parce que tu as fait
une série assez longue sur l'ia je pense
que il ya tout pour apporter de
précisions sur l'aspect technique peut
être aussi ouais j'ai trois premières
questions avant de laisser partir cette
occasion ses cartes qu'est ce qu'il faut
à faire de questions un peu nos leviers
d'action pour pour que le futur aille
aille bien ou mieux ça c'est tout mais
je pense qu'il faut déjà on discutait il
faut être pour participer
discussion c'est important de 11-10 pas
que le futur sera déterminé par d'autres
je pense qu'on a tous une petite voix
c'est une des choses laquelle on
aimerait bien d'exemplaires justement
c'est une mettre en place une sorte de
communauté
là on est en train de travailler sur
différents moyens de donner la parole
aux gens peut-être à travers une
plateforme y avoir plus de vision du
futur parce que c'est lorsque pendant sa
soirée écrire ce qu'on aimerait que le
futur soit on commence à façonner ses
idées et donc les maîtres venelles
premier partager ça donne aussi des
idées à d'autres et c'est comme ça qu'on
aussi qu'on entretient une sorte de de
feu d'idées qui peuvent engendrer des
innovations parce que c'est quelqu'un
après qui sait ce que les gens
deviennent dans la vie et qui peut
donner des idées à quelqu'un qui va
inventer et qui va être le prochain prix
nobel
c'est pas impossible je pense aussi
qu'il faut pas avoir peur de se lancer
dans une start-up pas avoir peur de
d'aller étudier un champ d'étude enfin
faut bien réfléchir aussi à ses choix si
quelqu'un qui est au collège aujourd'hui
ou au lycée c'est un seigneur est
extrêmement compliqué parce que on a
absolument aucune idée ce que le marché
du travail sera où le futur de de
l'emploi ou même n'importe quel secteur
finalement donc c'est difficile
aujourd'hui choisir une discipline
c'est à dire oh je vais docteur c'est
peut-être possible que dans cinquante
ans les docteurs on aurait pu parce que
ce sera désire donc c'est important
aussi de bien réfléchir à son évocation
et puis essayer de choisir des
disciplines qui vont influencer le futur
d'une manière positive donnée les
secteurs de l'énergie ou de la recherche
on ira génétique d'être ingénieur en
aéronautique sont chez moi et notre
occasion du couple et calais si tu veux
être résumé un peu ce podcast ou une
partie du podcast en un message clé quel
serait-il
ouais je dirais on a un message clé
c'est à avoir un peu d'optimisme à se
dire que oui
malgré les malgré la température
ambiante qui peut être négatif qui peut
être aussi un peu déprimante
on peut se dire que finalement il ya des
terroristes c'est terrible le
réchauffement climatique ce terrible les
inégalités hystérie demain en fait il ya
beaucoup de gens qui travaillent faudra
se dire quelque chose il ya beaucoup de
gens qui travaillent tous les jours pour
résoudre ces problèmes ça pour moi ça me
donne personnellement je vais en parler
mais je pense que c'est important aussi
le trot se dire il n'y a rien qui peut
être fait pour le futur c'était trop
tard ou ce genre de choses quoi ouais
parce que ouais comme toile il ya
beaucoup d'innovations qui sont là pour
ait pu même des changements éthique des
changements moreau sur nos valeurs on
réfléchit beaucoup plus à mesure que les
nouvelles technologies sont disruptive
ça nous donne aussi le l'occasion de
réfléchir à céder une grosse question et
de stationné un petit peu la direction
dans laquelle on a envie d'aller la
super présumés il est ce qu'il fallait
finir avec quelques recommandations de
vidéos podcasts livres aux personnes à
suivre
ouais bah je pense qu'on a parlé de
l'île de certains livres aujourd'hui un
des penseurs aujourd'hui on note l
artificiel qui est renommé pas mal
l'affluence influenceurs scénique bost
room
je pense que voilà il a encore récemment
sorti un papier assez intéressant sur
l'hypothèse du futur comme ça il n'ira
bhl avait passé cela pied ouais c'est
son dernier il a fait la tête froide
dans ce corps est intéressant et donc
oui ça donc il ya aussi j'aime beaucoup
sa maman
harris est ce un neuroscientifique un
philosophe très intéressant sur certains
sujets notamment liam aussi la morale
yuval noir harry je pense qu'il faut
lire ses livres sapiens amadeus et alain
telle une leçon pour matignon siècle
ouais il ya des débats intellectuels
récent qui a vraiment été écoutés parce
que il a mis une mis le doigt sur
certaines choses assez intéressantes
donc ça c'est en termes de littérature
et de type après en chaîne youtube
j'aime beaucoup fin je suis plus un dix
huitième anglophone l'ina sur des
questions plutôt colonisation spatiale
les grosses questions de l'espace c'est
plutôt sur qu'est-ce qu'une simulation
très très avancé sera capable de faire
c'est une chaîne s'appelle à isaac à
resserre ok ça intéressant puisque tu me
parles de cire de dyson de
mégastructures de créer des terres
artificielle et des cylindres donnent
ils sont assez fous atteint fonda que
j'ai sur ma liste des favoris pour
savoir vraiment ce que des conneries
mais voici non elle a évolué de corse
qui sait quelqu'un cas il ya une façon
de penser très intéressantes qu'elles
vont peupler seriez là ouais ouais c'est
vrai que l'après bush pendant toute la
liste m'a regardé en général voile est
toujours intéressant d'être de suivre
les ted n'était tôt que ce que celle a
toujours des idées qui qui sont le
mérite d'être connu en fait c'est un peu
le slogan foutu truc d'affluence est
super merci beaucoup
et merci gaëtan pour cette discussion et
merci aux auditeurs d'avoir suivi jusque
là
et je vous dis à la prochaine fois
probablement merci un carton
d'invitation